I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing,
but I'm going to do the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but
I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same
thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit of the same thing, but I'm going to do a little bit
well, I feel like I'm moving 5 miles an hour
I'm so tired
How are you I'm not I'm not gonna lie to you
At exactly four o'clock I woke up from a nap walked over to my computer impressed go live
So I'm still waking up
I'm waking up to the ashes
Okay, it might be a little bit delirious
Got my tea ready to rumble I
Gotta remember who I am who I am I
Also, so like I got an iPad stand
Thank you for your support those who look at my throne and such and I was trying to set it up so that I could use my
iPad almost like a third monitor and look at chat and it was working well except I could see
Like it was so tiny I couldn't see anything and I'm like oh
I'll have to lean forward and squint my eyes to see what the frick. I'm looking at
Oh
What are you why are you guys doing today? How was uh did you get double ASMR again from
throne a and and I say
By the way, is she be short for Shabilla
I'm too tired to come up with a snarky remark to that
Um, oh no, I see the Tomb Raider. I don't know where I am
Oh
You've got to melt model kids go sick, but you're here. I
like
some of you guys might saw me all I went to the doctors this morning and
And
Like
Going out into the world
Takes a lot out of me and interacting with people because I kept kept getting turned around like I kept
Accidentally going the wrong way because my GPS was messing stuff up
I was a little bit late and then the office is taken forever and so I was just so tired
When I got home, but then I had to do a bunch of other stuff to prepare for stream
And then like exactly three thirty eight is fell asleep on the couch
and knocked out
But uh, we're here we are here
She beat me in losses kind of be I have no sense of direction
Uh, I I never know where I am even in my town that in in my city that I've lived in for
My entire life essentially, I'm like, oh, which which road do I take? Where where am I?
It's not a miracle I'm awake right now. I did set an alarm
But I'm like, I know I needed to just like lay down for a bit and just gain my bearings
Um, but I hope you guys enjoyed Tomb Raider
with IC and then
ASMR with momay
I am quite E.P. I am waking up
Don't worry. I'll wake up though. I'm just like here. I didn't fall asleep till like 3 a.m
My whole sleep schedule is messed up ever since I streamed so late
A womb raider? Oh my god
I already made that joke
I already made the ash and dust joke
the
imagine dragons
Oh, you like imagine dragons. Well, imagine me dragon. He's nuts across your face
Got him
I forget to put my ooloo mouth on
I'm pretty good. I'm pretty I'm pretty I'm pretty uh
I'm as
I'm sort of smart as a whip that doesn't make any sense. But yeah, I have no idea what this game is about
Um, I know like it might be a visual novel
I went in for like a second and I saw that it was voice acted. So I turned off the voices. I'll be voice at voicing
See the characters today
And you guys can vote in the voices
Um, it's about bunny girls. Yeah, I like I haven't watched any gameplay
Haven't read
Anything about it. I know it was a flavor of the month game for a very for a little bit
And I'm like, okay, I'll play it
um
So we'll see we'll see
Yawns and finds I'm surrounded by bunny girls
I see this as an absolute win. Okay. I'm gonna love it
I also went in just in case because like when I went to purchase the game
I was like, oh wait, I hope there's not like surprise things that need to be censored. So I went and I double checked
Because I didn't know if it's gonna be like a hoonipop situation. You guys are all just like tricking me
And the whole world is against me tricking me pretending that stuff is normal
And then it's a crazy messed up game
um
Yeah, so I went in there wasn't any of that
I was like, okay, although
I did see like when I was looking at the steam page for like a brief second when I was purchasing the game
just like people's screenshots
And they're all ponzu shots
So I'm like, what am I getting into?
Kushi jokes scare exactly she doesn't know about the level that just opens what?
Excuse me. It's just a lot of fan service. It's on brand for me. What color today?
What the fuck does that mean? I'm white
Some I did I did tease a possible brown toggle
um
It's death less messed up than class of 09. I didn't expect it to be messed up
As much as class of 09 panty simulator with a side of alcohol
You think they meant my ponzu
I don't remember
um
Actually, these are my favorite pairs
It's like, uh, it's like rain like pastel rainbowy
lace
with flowers on it
And um
It's a thong
And it's like has a lot of light blue
It's nice to get my skin tone anyways. Um
Usually we're nothing but I had to go out into the world today. So I decided to you know bundle up before going on an excursion
I
Actually fucking hate thongs. I don't even know why I have so money so money so many
I need to um
buy
More underwear like some like cheekies
I uh, I accidentally so like I
I'm a huge fan of like the savage x fenty like rihanna's lingerie line
And I forgot to fucking cancel my membership because they charge $59 a month for membership
And you can skip the month mind you
And you can like save the money, but I swear to you
I thought I skipped the month and they charged me 60 bucks and I have to spend it on something and I'm like
Well, it looks like I'm getting panties looks like I'm getting panties
They have great stuff, but I'm like what the hell, you know
I'm like what the what the what the actual fuck?
Um, that's really high quality
It's mostly what I wear. Although I go to the pink store sometimes. Um
For a little something something
It's been 10 minutes and we're talking about pansos. Yeah, what did you expect?
Are you new here?
Wait a minute. Who are you?
What does she be
It's funny. You guys have got me saying erm what the sigma and erm what the scallop
I uh because like when I when my stream just wasn't loading when I press start
I was like, um
erm what the
What the scallop and then I just like audibly sighed out loud when I when I heard what I said
I'd be disappointed if you weren't still talking about random at this point random
You be it's she be it's a me. She be
Let's go and
Yep
I should put disclaimer. I'm tired of shit. I promise you. I'm not drunk
I'm just tired. I usually like listen. I made a big sacrifice
Streaming at the time that I do because around this time is normally my nap time
My family is notorious for napping
My mom's the only one that can't my whole dad's side of the family are napping champions and from
four to five
Prime nap time something I've like napped for like four hours before and I still managed to get to sleep
Is it depression? I don't know. Maybe she's born with it. Maybe it's
dysthymia
She be
Did you hear a twitter room of the likes you can see?
I can still see everybody's likes because I have not updated my twitter on my phone
So you can't hide from me
I know your secrets. I know when you're awake. I know when you've been bad or good. So be bad
For goodness sake
What is your favorite kind of vegetable um
Is a potato a vegetable I really like potatoes
Yeah, potatoes a vegetable
Yeah, because I didn't have like a seed
I was like the dumbest thing I've ever said is a potato a vegetable. Oh my god. Um
It's funny because like technically zucchini is fruit
tomatoes are fruit
Like carrots are vegetable and like leafy greens are vegetables
I really like all vegetables
I'm like trying to think of a vegetable. I don't like
Like because I'll just eat anything. I don't like like I like I'm not a huge fan of arugula, but I also eat it
I really like spinach. Yep. Mm-hmm
I like brussel sprouts. Did you know they've actually um engineered the bad flavor out of brussel sprouts now?
Because my dad used to hate brussel sprouts
And then he like threw some in the air fryer
And like with a little bit of oil salt and pepper and they were like really tasty nutty almost like an artichoke heart
And he's like this is not like what they taste like
Back then and then we looked it up and did research and they actually engineered the shit out of there
You hate bell peppers. I love bell peppers
Tomatoes are both vegetables and fruit depends on which taxonomy you're using. All right
I don't know what that means, but godspeed
But they didn't smell so strong. Yeah, they do still smell like, you know, the devil's asshole, but it is
Spinach over lettuce for salads 100% I like butter lettuce
um
Because it's similar to spinach
Or I'll use like butter lettuce for like a lettuce wrap pretty good
Why the fuck are we talking about vegetables? You know how much like this is how this is what I mean
I don't know somebody asked me a question. I'm like, all right talks 10 minutes explaining my answers
But her lettuce I barely know shut up get out of here
I think canned steam veggies turn people off flavor so much better
Baked in oil. Oh, yeah, I agree with that
I prefer all like
I'll eat steamed veggies because I like I like steamed broccoli or green beans. I love green beans
um
The best lounge chat. Yeah
Yapa be cotton bum
That's a me
favorite breakfast
You know
I love french toast
French toast I think was the first thing I learned how to cook after like learning how to like boil water
And like make eggs. I learned how to make french toast. My mom taught me how to make french toast
Um, and it was so fun that experience. Um
I burned everything, but you know, you live and you learn, but yeah, I love I love french toast
I love the french
toast
Especially if it's texas toast. I don't know
um
I'm I'm speaking in a very poor french accent
Because I'm half asleep, but um, I am it is how it is
Uh
No, I didn't I can boil water guys. I'm a very good cook
When you're a kid and you're learning you're not a very good cook
It's called eggy bread in england
That's fucking weird. It's not a better name. No, I don't like it
Don't X to doubt
If you've looked at my all account people have commended me on my cooking skills because I have sent I've taken pictures and posted some food
I have cooked
um
French toast is called lost bread and
I feel like there's a pun in there
I
Just found out the healthy frozen protein waffles taste and smell like the ben and jerry's waffle cones. Oh
Okay, but what brand?
I do love waffles though. I used to fucking live off of
um
My mom said I used to love french toast sticks and eggo waffles and then out of nostalgia the other day
I bought some
Eggo waffles, but I don't have any syrup or butter. So
I mistakes were made
Waffles versus pancakes. I prefer waffles
Like I love I really like pancakes, but like sometimes pancakes can be a bit too mushy for me
And I like the I prefer the texture of a waffle over a pancake and that like a waffle can hold syrup better
whereas a pancake
Um just becomes kind of just like soppy
I've read french toast sticks. Yeah, it's it's pretty much just like french toast
And you throw it in a toaster and you toast it in there
Or like a con confectionary confection oven or
an oven
My belgian side tell me waffles raw talking
I I have done that before but I prefer like I
I I'm weird and I prefer to eat waffles with my hands
like my mom
For some odd reason because it's not like I was going to impress anybody or have a luncheon with the queen
but she drilled etiquette in like proper
like
Using silverware into me
Like which forks and knives to use which like if you're at this sort of event what this means and what that means
um
I think she just wanted me to be like proper
Which isn't like a bad thing like teaching, you know, your child etiquette and
being you know behaved at the dinner table because I was like I remember
um
I would always have to say like can I be excused before I left the dinner table and I had you know all that stuff
And so I remember like one parent when I was over somebody's house
I would just like can I be excused and they're like why are you asking and I'm like
Because I always have to ask
Yeah, she maybe yeah manners make if she be it's funny. I was literally
I don't know why it popped in my head on the toilet, but I was randomly just sitting there. I'm just like
Manners make if the man that's like I didn't even watch Kingsman reach recently
Actually, that's a lie. I watched the Kingsman
I didn't finish it because it was boring
I got to the part past Rasputin
Rasputin
Poutine that's basically wants poutine now and I was like, all right
This is kind of weird
And it's kind of boring
I prefer the the first Kingsman movies moving on and then I fell asleep and then I just never bothered to watch it again
She'd be getting mad at her friends. I was because they served over over the wrong shoulder
No, like I don't even recall like a lot of that stuff anymore. I remember I went to like um a fancy restaurant with my parents
And this is the type of restaurant where if you get crumbs on the table
They come over and they have a little thing to take the crumbs off and they move them away
And they have like the multiple silverware and it's like that's like a my parents usually go there for their anniversary because it's a very like
pricey place
And I've been like sitting there and I'm like fuck
Which fork do I use for salad again? I don't even
my mom's like
That one I'm like, oh, thanks. Anyways
They lived a certain man
It was a long ago. He was being and strong in his eyes a flaming gold
That's the fucking I love doing that and just dance. It's like probably my favorite song to do in just dance
Besides, I think
Was I like that by Richard? Hold on. I like that just dance
By the talk by the
Elect was it the toxic revenge or what the fuck?
Toxic Avenger
Am I tripping I could have sworn I like that
By toxic Avenger was in just dance
I'm getting as toxic from Britney Spears
Very frustrated
Whatever I'm having I'm experiencing a Mandela effect for a moment
It's gonna be saver
I definitely want to like if when they get a 3d model 100 I want to do just dance
I'm like I need to get back
into like
Dance and shape
I'm just like a
I'm just atrophying in my chair
I
Think you had a cool dream toxic Avenger is a movie. No
I think your thumbnail got restricted. Are you fucking serious? I you know, I noticed that when I was on my iPad
I was just like wait a second
Why is it like grayed out
Like it was that like the three dots thing I I didn't know what that meant though, but that makes a lot more sense then
I'll fix it later. I blame my manager
They approved the the thumbnail
Throw some boobs in the thumbnail
Put some boobs in the thumbnail bitch for some boobs check out Azura's cover of boobs in the thumbnail
That it was leg but the gray was an artistic choice. It's gray in the homepage
I
Just more reminders that I'm probably never going to be monetized
Sometimes I fall asleep and I hear my bgm in my ears
And is I can't tell if I like it or not
Oh wake up
Oh, I need a non outfit. I was thinking about adding one of those to throw in like one of those, um
Vtuber outfits that I've been using for streams and stuff
I have to get rid of this bod based on what happened with other streamers. Why what happened to their vods?
Wait, I thought everyone got monetized and saying no, that's not true. We applied for monetization all at the same time
um
The majority of the other girls got it
I'm still I'm still under review. It doesn't have I'm just I'm
mentally preparing myself to be disappointed in case it happens
Serenity
Munchie be would go so hard
Does she know do they know
It was a priestess and a nun and another another iteration
Uh, sorry, don't you usually stream around this time? What are you doing girl?
Serenity I made you in a call of the lamb and you tried to
Well, like no, you didn't try to kill me. What was it?
You tried spreading falsehoods about my cult so I had a thorium prison
So you're currently in prison right now and call the lamb. I'm so sorry
Rip vod before streaming even started. What do you mean?
YouTube said no to bunny garden of up explain
Is there anything you can do I can reapply in a month
I
That's where I belong in prison
Big lazy
Uh, yeah, it would just it would just be
A month of like I'd have to reapply
Do I have a hat?
No
what
What's that a hat a crazy funky junkie hat ever slept hair and tidy
Oh, she looks like here at nightly. We've been there. We've done that. We see right through your funky hat
Do you know where that that's from?
I should be fine as long you skip over the in-game asmr. Really?
Why don't I have a hat
Was that from Hannah Montana close?
It's from another
another uh show
around that time
Wiped a week or so ago
Does that mean you're definitely not gonna get remember I I guys I have no idea. I don't I have no idea
maybe
The youtube coon will smile upon me and bless me with um
And bless me with
Monetization, but who knows if not
It is what it is
You can always support me on patreon even if you don't want to consume the content
Or you can always support me through stream loads or you can check out my merch. It is not the end of the world
Wizards of Waverly Place you got it
I need to do in your mom hat. That's a pretty good. That's pretty good
I would actually probably get that
somebody said uh
Uh man, I love fishing hat
Ha ha ha
Like trying to oh no, I'm not I'm not I'm not worried about uh, she likes to yap just as much as me like mother like daughter
Donate my imaginary
I'd be like, all right
Pay your tithes every month and just pretend your name is green
No member strips number member strips membership streams though. Um
Well, yeah, I'm not
I'm not too worried. I'm kind of just like doomin about it just like mentally
Because you know, what is that thing that like Wednesday Adam says?
If you expect the worst you can't be disappointed or some shit, but like yeah
member strips member strips is where you get chicken strips sent to you
uh once a month in the mail and the box that they come in has my face stamped at them
But it's like, you know that one
Gif of like a chicken
Pole dancing or it's like a rabbit. I don't know
Just pretend it's a chicken
So it's a chicken pole dancing and that's like my face is on the chicken
And then you get chicken strips from sheebie. That's
Chicken member strips. Yep
They good. They're the best
Nothing nothing but the best for my baby girls
Okay
Thank you harlot
Folded hands folded hands folded hands
Thank you. It didn't pop up because I had muted my um desktop audio. I forgot to turn back on
But uh, thank you harlot
But don't yeah, don't
Don't
Worry about me
It's mostly frustrating because I had like I want to do
Like the membership streams that I have in mind
um
My face. No, my face isn't on the strips
It's on
The box that holds the strips unless
You would prefer both
We might do that
Ow, I just like
Hit myself with a nipple really hard
Uh, excuse me. That was a sleepy burp
All right
Go abgm
It's time to play
Bup bup bup bup buddy gordon
Where the fuck is it?
Can I kiss the boo boo to help you know
Can I be can I be can I be tmi for a second?
So mine are pierced and so sometimes I just get like hooked on stuff
Or I'm just like bump into something like
And that's like the worst thing
I don't
No, no, I'm not ripping them. They're not my nipples aren't getting ripped off guys
It's more it's like imagine
Like if it like, you know
Actually, I don't know if it's like this at all because I don't have balls
But imagine you're going to zip up your pants and like a little bit of your ball gets like caught in the zipper
It's like a little bit. It's like a little less than that
That's what I'm assuming
But imagine that on your chest
Because it's like, you know, like I'm not gonna elaborate. Anyways, I was just fucking loud. Ha
I've had it before it hurts ouch
You get in the hospital when you get caught in your zipper
Well, I'm I didn't mean like if you're caught caught like you can't get out
I mean like when you kind of zip it up and just like pinches you a little bit
Like because I'm like, I've done that. I've done that to my pussy lip before and I'm like, ah
I'm just like, ah like gira. Ah, and then I'm just like quickly
Okay, maybe it's not as bad as that
That's imagine you guys are such fucking babies
You nipple piercings hurt once they're there
Uh for the first like couple months. Yes, they're pretty tender
I remember I went so I went with Salem who I talk about often
She we had only known each other for a week. Mind you. I'm like, hey, do you want to come with me and watch me get my nipples pierced
And she's just like, oh my god. Yes, sure
Because I want to walk like I want to get them done too and I'm like, okay, let's go and um
We go there
first one goes in and I'm like, ow
That really hurt and I look over and look at Salem's face and her face is like
Completely mortified like
And then the piercer was telling me so usually the adrenaline kicks in
Only for the first one and then kind of tapers off
For the second one so a lot of people don't get the second one done. I'm like, fuck it. Put the second one through
And they did that and it hurt worse and I was like, ah
And then I couldn't like put anything against my chest for like a month
That's when you know what? I went right back to work
Like because I because there's a piercing place in the mall and I just went back to work
I went on my lunch break. I'm like, fuck it
I'm a badass bitch
Um, what kind of period I just have barbells
Um, but they look cute in a shirt and stuff. I know some people don't like them
Like but like I know straw knees, um
Straw knees, uh has model has them
He he who who?
My model doesn't have it though
But it it would be on brand for me to have it
But like I did I have a high pain tolerance
Straw knees model don't worry about it. Hi mom
Hi mom did mom read? Did you hi?
Hello
Hey, I'm just presuming off of your alt account
Hey, hey
Hey, listen, they probably watched like 30 minutes. So I was normal for the first about 30 minutes and now we're not normal
I didn't read you, but
Can you guys hear Raina singing the song of her people in the background
She be strong as she be's Donnie Donnie mommy. No
She might be my mother
She doesn't don me though
Wait, what do you normal what about I already forgot what I was talking about
But um, yeah, I have a high pain tolerance. So she doesn't hurt me
Not sorry. She was a doll. It's too soft. She's I am also dollar. Yeah, I'm
Am I the tallest girl?
Or is there I might be the tallest girl. No
It's a tallest girl
Am I the tallest girl out of all I can't remember
Straw knees a freaking small ass chick. Let me tell you that though. I could probably rest my arm on her head
Uh
Why did I choose this game because I had the word bunny in it and I wanted to play something bunny related
I'll take a seat
Well, no, I meant like like actual heights like I meant like rtx model heights
Out of normal heights. Yes. Is there is the tallest because she could fucking turn into a skyscraper
I'm just six feet in heels
I'm normally like five six
in my little
Wait, am I five six in heels? Does that mean I'm
I'm just thinking because if I'm a hundred and sixty eight centimeters while I'm wearing my red heels
Does that mean I'm actually like five four?
Whole is my life a lie
Holy
You're the tallest girl since there are cheats because he's he's a giant that's true. She just like stays tall
I'm getting bullied for my height. We made it quick itself
Because normally like because normally I'm like I'm five eight five nine
But
uh
2d she be
is five six
But I don't know if that's with heels or without heels. So, uh
Design papa. I'm gonna need you to get on that and give me my canonical can on kanan con
height
Yep
words
English exists
Absolute uh
absolute short stack
I'm not I'm taller than the majority of people I interact with on a daily basis. Yes, it's mostly my cats
But when I go back to work, I am literally taller than so many fucking people
She be who is the ebony of this game, you know, the draco living
Who cuts because I don't know. I don't know. Maybe the girl with the black hair who kind of looks like, uh
That one chick from
device halo device
That sounds so bad
But that's
I just I just literally noticed right now that she kind of like looks like the girl from device
Hey quick question. Why is your thumbnail gray? I think my thumbnail was nuked
Yeah
So, uh
Hey strani, can you tell a manager to make me another thumbnail with a cover up?
So I can put that up instead because it got yoinked
Thank you mom. I love you mom. You're the best mom
Are you firing peeler allegation? Please do not make it cop color
Yeah, my thumbnail got yip zippity doodad zippity dade
It wasn't even it was literally me standing almost like I was in a fucking t-pose because
I did an emote for my face for the thumbnail. So I'm just kind of just like
Standing there. This is it was literally that I will show you what it was. Hold on
It was literally me going like this
No, not even with that just like
That's what I got it nuked
My thumbnails might all get yoinked. I won't I wouldn't be surprised that that happens
I
Guess I just have to become
Flat, you know because flat's justice and all
Looks deviously at mother
Maybe I just have to become cute and funny looks deviously at mother
It shows up in some fever blanket. Yeah, I noticed that
I'd be too powerful with that you're right you're right
I
Do they know
They're gonna know they're not gonna know
I'm already cute and funny
You know what all is awesome. So I ordered some stuff from amazon for my um
Uh asmr this week. What's today?
Wednesday tomorrow's thursday power wash collab. I don't remember what day my own asmr stream is
But I got like pop rocks for really cool
Trigger and the taste really good too. I already had like one pack. Well, I'm finishing it up right now
I don't know
As this will get nuked
for mouth sounds
I don't know if johnny did you already do this tell me a news and um
Did you already do pop rocks? I feel like you did
Yeah, it's really I feel like it's really nice. She did it with her feet sweat. Oh, I didn't know that part
Yeah, I already did a couple days ago they finally came in
Thank you, mother
Oh my god, why are you so prep fucking precious? I can't
A file name
And it's just a fucking screenshot
Oh, I can't you're too good for this earth. Oh my god, let me just
I'm keeping this thumbnail
I'm just straight keeping it even if uh, they come back around
To fix it. I'm just I'm keeping this one up
I
Graphic design is my passion is straw knees passion. I should say
I can picture I can picture your silly little face go
In Scottish just
I hope you got can you guys see it your work? Can you guys see it?
Laughs in Scottish gasps in Spanish
Anyways games
My dude this loud holy fuck
It's a fucking loud it's perfect or or it's the thumbnail is perfect
Is is the is the sound fine
Bye straw knee, thank you for stopping by and making me an amazing thumbnail
I
Oh wait, uh, can I go back?
I got 15k again in my pocket. Isn't that like a hundred fifty bucks or something?
You know that face on your makes and spy x family that got me and I guess yes exactly that one
All right
Trying to think of a voice
My company fired me
It is what it is. It's not the first time it's happened
I'm thankful they hired me in the first place. I have nothing but gratitude for the company
My boss even cried for me when they fired me. He said I'm sorry. I couldn't help you out
They told me that this company isn't the right fit for me and that there are other places where I could shine
It was nice of them to say that
Is there really somewhere out there some place that would take in a fool like me?
Hi to come
Even if I could get another job somewhere else. I would just mess everything up for the people there
Ellipses
Maybe my life ellipses is done for I didn't even think it has started
ellipses
It's only been a minute in and I'm thinking about killing myself
Time to drink my problem. So
I guess he's the goth one. He's he's ebony
I
I'm pretty sure there's a bar somewhere in this building
Oh, she's 3d holy shit
Uh
You just feel so cool in my mouth
What sort of voice should we she have
I
We're eating pop rocks
Childhood friend voice givers, okay. I'm just gonna put it to a poll
I
Like how you call it like an emmy voice when you just want me to do a lulley voice
Me sounds less girls conny voice
Give her a lisp
There's lollipabas
Oh by lollies aren't the girls voice in jp. Yeah, but I'm fucking doing the voices. Why do you?
I
Why would I why would any time I'm reading a visual novel? I'm the one doing the voices
My only excuse to do funny voices because the other times I do it when I'm just playing games. It doesn't make any fucking sense
Okay
That wasn't good
Um cute and funny voice Scottish really condescending childhood friend
Or
Just wolf like a dog
Um I'll just do like
Deep voice I don't know what that would be but yeah
Her southern oh, I want to put southern damn it have fun
We have three other two other girls to voice so
Six out of yeah, no Toma knows I can do better
Speaking of which me and Toma have a collab coming up next week
The little pokemon smash
She is bringing out one of her characters trinket I'm
Very excited
It'll be so good
That's my cat
How much you I'm she's gonna say smash a low-punny literally someone mentioned this a couple streams ago
I literally was just like oh, I would do horrible things solo punny. I literally said that
Was that the mom I have a toy. Yeah, she has a she has her fluffy ball
She likes to take it into the bathroom. She likes to scream in the bathtub
Don't ask me why she does that. That's just she's
That's I call it singing the song of her people. She's just letting the other cats know that she has caught something
That's funny because boomie and fia don't do that
But they'll go and look like run to her all concerned
Mr. Mime
I'll just I'll save it for the the collab
But yeah, please check out uh, Toma I have a lot of collapse uh next week
Can you combine option two and three
I
Scottish cute and funny boys
Stare
I'm looking at you
And I'm thinking that you're a bloody wanker. No, that's not gonna that's hard actually
I'm I'm staring at you
I'm looking at you
Raina, what the fuck are you doing? I don't know what my cat is doing school and forever
This calypso is minging no
All right, but I'm sorry condescending childhood friend one
Raina, please
Mommy is straight Raina
Okay, I'm sorry I need to go tell her that she's did a good job hold on
Oh
She prays like that
I
Mean it's a podcast with uh me and Raina
Stare
I'm sorry
Just throwing out a guess here, but did something bad happen to you? It's like it has a twinge of valley girl, you know
That's why you're trying to drink it forget everything or
Uh, sorry, excuse me
Are you trying to get me to go to your hostess club?
Yeah, you're wrong. You just happened to catch my eye before I got to work
I'm feeling when I come on stream to mess with you you come on stream to mess with me
I ain't even reading the rest of that mods
Hang him
By his piggy toes
From the ceiling spinning him around while you waterboard him
All right, thank you
He looks so tired as if your life is over
Oh, this is like really quiet
I put the bgm too quiet I think
This is fucking on
You look tired I can fix that
I
Ever seen the grapefruit technique
My soul
The customers in my bar I don't need to do anything for people to come to wonderland
It's a classic technique just look up the grapefruit technique make sure you're alone though and that your headphones are in
just so you know
It's a
beautiful black woman
Holding a holding a grapefruit and she she goes over techniques. So highly recommend it ladies that are watching
I
Was in a group when I saw the oh bless your heart
Very great technique 10 out of 10
It's nice to see that my male viewers are very progressive and using it as well. Good job guys
Happy pride
You might be right I knew it. Yes. Oh
Sorry, this isn't something to be happy about. I'm sorry. I shouldn't have hit it right on the bullseye
It's so sad to think your life is over
Yeah, I know
What what should I do?
Oh, sorry, I'm thinking what should I do if I invite him in then I'll really become a tout
What the fuck does that mean?
But I can't leave someone so hurt out in the cold
Girl, what are you talking about?
Um, why are you just talking? I'm right here. I can hear what you're fucking saying
Got it. You don't have to come into the shop. You can just have a sneak peek. That's right
I don't know what the fuck is going on. The truth is I work here
Hello one of those is actually me
The girl what the almost said the girl with the black bunny ears. They both fucking have them the girl in the yellow. She's me
She's just she's me
You
Make sure if you ever have grapefruit, uh, you shouldn't eat grapefruit while you're taking medication and it's not safe
Tip from uh
Your your neighborhood dom
Literally human
Hmm, I didn't know they opened this kind of bar here. It's someplace where I can drink with girls
I've never been in a shop like this before. It's clean and the girls are cute. I've only been to the really
Disgusting fucked up ones where the girls look like they have track marks up their arms and have been huffing
Powder for hours. You see me. What are you saying? Sorry? I got off on a tangent
I guess I'll give it a try
Ah, you're gonna get me in trouble, sir
Huh, so I can't come in what the why the fuck did you show me this if I can't come in
That's all for today. I'll just give you a glimpse if you come inside then I'm really a tout
What the fuck is a tout?
I give you the right to come to the shop as a customer
Since when the fuck do you give me the right to go to a bar where I pay money to hang out with you
Anyways, whenever you're interested, I'll be waiting for you to come. Why did you just ignore me?
You're so sincere
Don't forget your life isn't over you'll be okay. I know you will
I can tell in your eyes. So please hand over your wallet
Huh, so I was just kidding
Right now, even if it was small, I know you smiled. My dick's not small. That means you're not done yet
Thanks, I guess fucking bitch
I'll be here at the shop waiting for you. I'm looking forward to the next time we can see each other and I can rinse your wallet
All right, I'll let you go
What the fuck was her deal? She was so strange. She doesn't even know me
But I guess I do feel a little better
Kind of tinted in my pants seeing that girl bent over that table
Oh, I'm such a simple guy
Now I don't know I'm making myself fucking laugh
Now I don't know if I really want to get drunk and forget everything
I just want to go home
Ellipses
What the fuck is all night I thought though it's like a weird version of the girl is poster
My life isn't over, huh?
ellipses
No way. Why would I take something a girl said to me? Seriously? We're not even know her name
I don't even remember what her face looks like. I was just staring at her tits
She didn't seem to be joking around but
You know her tits
Ellipses
I mean, it's not like anyone has ever told me that my life is done besides me. I contemplated suicide probably about 30 minutes ago
I'm the only one who thinks that
If I don't finish it myself, maybe it's still possible to start again
Seriously starts masturbating
Tout a person soliciting comfort customers
Oh
Attempt to sell something typically by pestering people in aggressive or bold manner
That doesn't make any fucking she wasn't even being aggressive though
Why
Oh
Hello, I'm sorry for calling you without notice. You know how you were saying work was busy and you needed help
Did you still need help if you'd like would you take me?
In my anal virginity
It's me on the other end. I'm like fine. We'll hire you come on down to wonderland
Here I did owe your mom a favor
It's been a week since I started my new job. What should I use my money on?
That being said me being positive was all thanks to her
Not really
It was very superficial what she said because we just met should I go back to that chick shop?
Oh shit, okay, how much is that in american money?
Cool this is more money I have in my bank account probably
It's like 300 bucks. Yep still accurate
Oh, baby a triple. Oh baby a triple. Sly Saber tipped three dollars and 33 cents. Thank you Saber use my money on shebe
Oh, thank you. Your tips are appreciated tips fedora mashibi
Somebody made like a really hilarious edit of all of our
Of all of our debuts in 2.0's and I could not stop laughing. It's like 40 minutes long
I can't
It's it's called. I think it's like veal or debuts except it's just memes
Please give it a watch
You watched it. It's so hilarious
Like I was crying laughing because he opens up my portion with hey slaves
And I was dying laughing at scrawny's part. Oh, it's so fucking funny
Please yeah, please watch it give that give that person some some clicks
They deserve it for all the memes they threw in
Uh, it's so hilarious. Azur's was really funny too
Oh, so I can enter the shop safe
Let's do it. Oh look
I can't get out
No
Why why can't I just click on stuff and I have to press my back button?
I can't go anywhere I can can I go to my calendar? Okay. I have to go to the shop
I
Can sleep
I can oh, I am taking so many panty shots
job hunting
Wait, I thought I had a job. Why would I need to get another job?
I can gift a vacation
So this is just be a fucking
Sugar daddy simulator I can gamble
I'm rubbing my hands together blackjack and hookers blackjack and hookers blackjack and hookers
Femme Domson am I just uh am I just
Am I just uh a piggy? I'm just a little little piggy
Guys by the way, I just want to let you know I don't do
I don't do that side of bdsm because
It's very manipulative
A lot of the women who who do that side of uh bdsm
Only do it because they know they get money. They don't care about
People that they work with
Don't approve of it. I don't like it
I've been I've been asked before if I will do uh financial domination
No
I am just me and you donate if you want to
And it is appreciated
I told my parents by the way, I have a surprise for them because I'm going to give them the uh the 200 dollars
that you guys donated um
In the stream where I like I mentioned that my dad was very sick
And so my parents are like, oh what's happening? And I'm just gonna give it to them. I'll I'll tell you guys what their reaction will be
um
because
I know they'll really appreciate it and they seemed like super like what are you?
My courtesy of my awesome streaming fans of my parents are like my dad was like
Oh emoji and my mom was just like, oh, they're so sweet. So
Yeah, my parents do know that I live stream. They're very supportive. They know that I also do um
That I do NSFW audios my I'm very I'm very
honest with my parents
My dad when I told them I got the uh the got into viola
My mom was like, oh my gosh. Yay. And my dad was like, yay
And I'm like explaining to them like the sort of content I'll be making like ASMR my parents know asmr is
And then my dad's like, okay. I have to ask
Are you doing any sex work? And I literally was like, uh
uh
Lude audios
He's like, I don't want to know
I don't want to know
But I will be taking my cut because I taught you how to do voices and I'm like, fuck you dad
He's like, I'm just gonna take credit for your well your great reading skills and uh your ability to do voices
And I would like my cut and I'm like, all right dad
He's like, just you know 20% I'm like my mom's just like my mom's like redacted. Stop it. Stop teasing her
Then my mom's like, but I want to be on your channel
I'm like, okay
My parents are fucking leeches guys. Just kidding. No, they're very supportive
I love them to death. They're very proud of me because they know I've wanted to be a content creator for a very long time
I think it was this shop here. I'm a bit nervous though. Why is this have like a they have like a menu outside?
Like it's a restaurant
Me more tea
Parents are sick
Oh anonymous tipped one dollar. Thank you anonymous queen our entire singular dollar from your pay piggy
Good job piggy
Now we're gonna do a retweet game where I'm gonna have everybody retweet and every five retweets is five dollars
and whatever the else the fuck that they say when they do those weird ass things and
Then I want to get a manicure and then
You're a piggy. I'm gonna rinse the peg. Give me your wallet
Vodcon she's a natural. No, it's because so when I first um
When I finally was able to log into my NSFW. I mean my alternative account
Um on twitter. I was like trying to go through and there's just like a lot of like fucking like sex bots and I'm like, uh
Okay, and like the majority of them were
goddesses and queens and
mistresses
And they were all just doing like like had that verbiage and I'm like what the fuck is like I'm like
Why is this on my timeline? I started just like following like
anti artists
To meet your person and then I finally went away
I'm like fuck this timeline. I don't want these bitches on my timeline
It's free money
Yeah, but I don't feel good about it
Like a tip is different because you're tipping me because you're enjoying my content
What they're doing is they're
They're like they're not doing it because they want to
assist in
Trying to say this so that it's
Okay for you too, but at this point I kind of don't give a fuck
uh, they don't
really care about like
Helping out
their little piggy, you know
They just want the money
they don't care about like the actual like
relationship of it
And it's like the respect of it
because there's
Yeah, I don't know never mind
Yeah, they're not really entertainers. It's like like and the girls just like had their fucking feet out
and they're like
Send me a tribute of 20 dollars to DM me and I'm like what the fuck is this
It just I'm sorry just like it generally like irritates me
But yeah, but then just donate who don't enjoy that but I also think I'm like it's kind of
It's kind of predatory
Unless you have a lot of expendable income, you know, but
I don't judge the people who get pleasure from it. I don't that's fine. You do you
I'm not a huge fan of the people that take advantage of those people
That's it
And those bots are annoying and most of them are fake anyways, so most people are just DMing some random
cash app of like a dude
in
Texas
Who stole his wife's speed picks and is rinsing out piggies
Hey, at least I'm in his family could get to disney
Problem is that some of those men are just having their low impulse control tickets. That's that's what I mean
That's another point like it's there's that as well 100%
I would like to youtube money, but I gotta admit it. Yeah
I want someone like
First and foremost take care of yourself
That's all I say
A day in white tipped one dollar day in white
So what you're saying is they want the tip but don't care about the tip
Exactly
Anonymous tipped five dollars based
Based, thank you. I know I was thinking for the tip, but I like how I'm trying to explain to you that you need to be financially
like
So I'm like you guys don't see me right now, but I'm holding my phone
I'm cradling my phone in my hands like I'm holding your face in my hands
Misaka best tipped four dollars
Thank you for not taking advantage of me now. Here's a measly four dollars for madam
Kisses your shoes. Kisses your shoes. Good job. Thank you. I'm kidding. Um, I'm cupping and holding your face
I'm not choking you yet
Now I am
I scared booby I feel really bad
I started like choking my phone and he just ran away
I
You know, it's important you don't crush the center. It's the sides of the neck because you're trying to cut off the
The
our toy
Named sword tipped six dollars and ninety cents hot hot
Because you don't want to crush their windpipe
But a flood flow not air flowing precisely
Anyways, as I was saying, I'm stroking your beautiful face right now a.k.a. my phone. Um, let me give you a little kiss
Oh, I just shut off my monitor shit
Okay, um
There you go inhale that before I continue
Take care of yourself
The anime girls that you watch and you support
They appreciate you they care about you, but make sure you pay your bills on time
Make sure you eat make sure you do self-care and self-love
They will be okay
All right
all right
Ponds beautiful or us both
I heard the hand
And you made
Anonymous tip twenty dollars. Thank you, madam. You're the best
Hafi zero zero two tip six dollars and ninety cents. I don't fall for those kind of scams
Anyway, here is my investment in shiba coin to the moon
Anonymous tipped fifteen dollars harder mistress
Thank you for the tip. I'm just choking your chicken right now
Well, aren't you just this this is going against one dollar and fifty cents. This is reverse fandom
We are being financially submissified. Oh my god
I'm not even trying to do like reverse psychology or anything
You guys are just fucking
I can't even think of a word to insult you if that's how much I'm frustrated with your kindness
Why does my fan base have to be such nice fucking people pieces of shit
Supporting your creators that you love
Terrible
Anonymous tipped fifty dollars get spoiled
For the fifty bucks
We're just we're just tell them
What was that sound alert? I don't know. Don't don't hit fifty bucks. I'm fat and I'm kidding
It's me going I'm gonna pre
How dare you financially support me especially since office jobs suck
Yeah, it's kind of like
I have this weird thing where I'm like I like
Like I want to be a streamer full-time
But if I'm a streamer full-time that means I have to you know, mostly rely on you guys for
To just like let me live
And I don't like putting that responsibility on people
but I also
like
That little imposter syndrome like don't spend your money on me
Because I'm like I have like I have a part-time job now and I'm doing okay
Like I just hate taking money from people. I don't know like it's just weird
The sweetest
Anonymous tipped five dollars. Thank you anonymous and like I know scrawny is the same way
She's like support the girls support the girls and I'm also like support the girls
I'm like the shittiest one. Why me?
Anyways anyways enough of that fucking shit. I'm gonna make some tea
Anyway, he gets really excited when I'm talking to him. He walks like he's drunk
Really just jumps around a lot
Off-rocks wakes me up
Hi
But uh, thank you guys I'm coming over I have my headphones on um
Unless thank you for your support. I appreciate it. I care about you guys. Um
It's only been like a week and a half
And I am just so thankful and feel like I don't deserve any of it
But I do because I'm your mistress stomps on your face. Fuck you
I'm the best you've ever had bitch. I hope my neighbors can't hear me because I was so
So
She was my first ever exposure that led me to the other girls and I found her funny amusing
I couldn't wait until debut and streams began. So I'm pretty happy to see your whole Thanksgiving. Oh, thank you
Thank you
I appreciate it. You guys are like you guys are too good to all of us. That's what I mean like you guys
um
Like
Only know an itch and tipped $100
Please have my wallet. I mean my wallet. I mean
Oh, I'm gonna pray what the fuck anonymous tipped $100
We love you madame. Please step on us
guys
Fucking mad lads. Thank you. Only no only chan
Anonymous tipped $2. Is this how we win? Do we spoil her until she has a mind break?
Thank you
Oh, I what I was gonna say, I'll say it from across the room. You can't see me. I'm waving. Hello. Hi. I'm far away. Um
Like I added
Guys are gonna make fun of me and that's okay. I don't mind it because I'm a grown bitch. All right
If you're gonna call me a bitch you better put sense in it in front of it
Um, but I put on my throne a bed frame because I don't have one
I've been sleeping on a mattress on the floor for almost two years now
Like you know that one picture
Of that guy like like he's like uh write my apartment. It's literally like a tv
In like a lawn chair
My apartment was that for the longest time
And you guys are just so nice and somebody bought me a bed frame and I'm like
Oh my god, I don't have to sleep on the floor
People are too kind
That's like I I hope that like when I become big enough
I can spread that sort of love, you know, like uh do like uh charity streams
I think that would be really cool
That would be really neat
The water ah
Bring myself in the water
But yeah, like I would love to also just like help out smaller creators
By like collabing with smaller creators or like um
Maybe like
Taking someone in a community who like wants to be a vtuber like helping them fund their model
I feel like that would probably go bad, but you know, I'm just too nice for him
Do I need help? Okay
I know someone who's went to k and sold us on the streamer. I remember it when I
um
One of my friends you like uh, one of my like uh, I'm gonna pray Jesus fuck anonymous tipped 50 dollars
Here's to a future bed frame also. Give some to your dad. No, I have a bed frame, but thank you
I will I'll let him somebody might supply some of my comic books or something. Um
He'll he'll he'll treat himself
It's like I don't know like starbucks coffee or something. Uh
when
I first started streaming one of the people I became mutuals with
She just she started shooting later than me and then someone donated her 7k dot like 7k
I remember the context as to why they were just like
And just like whipped it at her during stream and I'm sitting there watching the stream
I'm like, what the fuck like people just like people are yeah
I was like, holy crap
people just like
I just want I just want to know I'm like, what did they do as a job?
Like, you know those guys that like do those tiktoks. They're like, hey
So what do you do for a living? I just want to ask those people what they do for a living
I just buy one big bed frame and combine them
Crazy
Saudi imagine like this
Like a Saudi prince just like really being obsessed with vtubers. That's actually kind of awesome
But um
Like but it's but it's you guys like I I need to
Make this point to you. It's you guys that keep the vtubing community afloat
Don't ever forget that without our fan base
There would be no us there would be no vtuber vtubing
So that's why your support means a lot
However, you know, there's a fine line just because you do donate does not mean you're entitled to
Uh all the vtubers attention, etc
Just yeah
I don't think I really need to elaborate on that because you are all adults
Mostly some of you I presume here
Uh, I'm gonna get rich so I can do the ties right like I like so like
I always said to myself. I'm like, okay
If I ever blow up and become like a vtuber, fuck you money. I'm just throwing it at other streamers
I'm just fucking you left right. You get cash. You get cash
You get because I'm not someone who like needs a lot like I'm cool
All I want is a house and I'm good. It's literally it. I want a house and debt-free
I'm just living with my cats and my chickens and my goats
And my quail. I've decided I want quail by the way
And I want to run a rescue and that's it
That's it
I don't care for fucking fancy cars. I don't wear designer because that's fucking stupid
So I'm like, yeah, we're chilling
We're chilling
In my btsm room. Yep
imagine
I get a house and I just thought I have like a red room from like 50 shades
And I just film everything in there
I like the cat cam and it's just like
There's a little like bed and on a like like human furniture like I have somebody just like sitting there just like holding my cats up
No peacocks, uh
I don't know what I would do with peacocks when I sell the feathers
And
I also want to pay off my mom's debt and my dad's debt buy my parents a house
I mean, it's like an overlay, but I don't I guess considering your don't
Don't go to the basement. That's where mercy is though mercy lives in my uh
The the apartment below me
The the like the what is it like the in-law suite or whatever it's called. I don't remember it's called
I don't know if they call it the same thing in other places outside of america, but like normally there's like a whole other like
livable space below like the main house that usually people
Like have their family live in so mercy's down there. She's in the basement
With her, you know senpai. She likes to tie up. I don't really you know question it or anything
I
Keeps all yeah, exactly. She keeps all you guys there feelers. Just one go. I made a joke. I'm like veeler content house when
I mean we're all like
It's just zoe burger, but like v2 burgers
You could sell farm that's what I want to do. I want to sell chicken eggs and I want to sell quail eggs
And stronti stronti is like this. I'm telling you me and her are the same person
I'm just brown and she's scottish because she said she wants to do the same exact thing
She just wants to have a little nice sanctuary and this like live in the countryside or some shit and take care of animals
And I love her for that
Has any content house gone well? No
We're changing that
We'll have to move to one country for a content. I don't know what would be the best place for us to move
Hmm
What kind of browned on you the biracial kind I don't what flavor of black are you?
Texas I'm not fucking going to Texas
You
No, I have had people so like again I work in retail people always because I'm very ethnically ambiguous looking
um
I got mistaken for so many different things
because I just
I don't know. I'm like fucking mystique from x-men. I just look like everybody
except asian
Actually, no, that's a lie one time somebody thought I was blazian
I thought I was mixed because how I like did my makeup and like it was when I was really into k-pop idols
So I did my makeup like them and it gave me a little bit of like a
Little blazian look and I was like I look hot as fuck
But I'm not
I'm blue. Yes, I'm blue
What's my hex code?
Hey, but what a candle would you ever want to come up here? I've actually been yeah, this is I
I guess this is zatsu
So much for playing a game. I hate myself
um
I've been to kebek and I've been to motel. Uh, I do like those places
So do you love zatsu's every stream is a zatsu in disguise. Is this like aim street?
I
It's because I get distracted
And I go off on tangents and then I want to elaborate on those tangents
And then you guys ask me another question and then I get more. It's your fault. It's all I'm gonna say
Oh, her name is how the fuck do I know her name now?
Ah, hold on. Yes, sip a tea before I start this
I don't even I'm not even diagnosed ADHD
I'm just I'm just fucking weird
Chat reflects the streamer good point
Nine more hours and we hit the daily insert interns quota
I don't even get questioned people thought I was Chinese Japanese Korean, but I'm Filipino and just monolingual and I stuck with me
Oh, yeah, I understand. Um, oh, yeah, but I'm my my story. I'm just gonna do it then I'll do I'll say my story
Then I'll continue with the game. I fucking promise
I'm adding to my goal list like actually
Do nothing but a game for the for two hours
Well, that'll kind of well good thing we're playing power power watch simulator tomorrow because then I can yap and game
I'll probably just end up standing around and the girls are doing all the work and I'm just like
Shabby shut up
Um
So this person came in
And they were speaking to me in Spanish
And I'm like, lo siento no habla espaol
um
I only speak English
And they were just like what and I'm like, yeah, they're like, but you look Spanish and I'm like, I'm not
they're just like
Yeah, but you're Spanish and I'm like, but I'm not and they're like
You're spanish. I'm like, I'm I'm black and they're like, no, you're not. I'm like, what the fuck they're like
You don't look black and I'm like
My mom is white. I don't know what you want me to tell you
I'm mr. Worldwide. I'm she be worldwide and the person's just like, well, you look Spanish
And they're like, okay, what type of black are you?
I'm like
I'm Haitian. I'm half I'm half Haitian
And then I'm like a bunch of other
white things
literally I have like a
15 thing list
on my mom's side of what I am
And they're just like, oh, but like
Haiti's like right next to the Dominican. So you're pretty much Spanish and I'm like
Oh my god
You're like you came from there. I'm like, no, I was I was born in America
Please
And I'm just sitting there and then they would like speak in like spanglish to me
And it's all so hard because I because I worked at my job for so long and we have a very large Spanish speaking population
Um, I do know quite a bit of Spanish and I can kind of usually follow along to what people are saying
so
She would slip into Spanish and I would just respond in English and so she's like
She looked at me and said you're fucking lying to me
In Spanish and I'm like, no, I'm not lying to you. She's like, how do you know what I'm saying? And I'm like, I'm
I just know a little bit of Spanish like what are you?
But it's funny because then like but
It's it's I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm not gonna tell you my last name
But I will say my last name is Arabic
But I'm not
I'm not I don't even know where that comes from and so people customers
who
Hear my last name that are like Middle Eastern or from Africa or from what they're just like
Oh speaks to me in Arabic and I'm just like
And then I have people who are from Egypt because apparently I look at gypsum
They're like speaks to me
in the main language of Egypt and I'm like, no
And people who think I'm like Cape Verdean and they're just like speaks to me and Cape Verdean and then
I also know a little bit of Chinese
So people will be like, oh
Are you half Chinese? I'm like, no
All I said was Niho mom
Um
Yeah
My last name. Yeah cotton bum is an Arabic last name. I don't know the
Yo
But yeah, I'm I'm very it's very fun because I usually because customers will be like, okay
What are you? I'm like guess and so I get like the widest fucking range of guesses
You know that like one guy who um
What's his name?
things about Cody co
Noel Miller is that his name?
Yeah, who did like they were like big on vine and all that shit
You know how everybody like tries to guess his race that is how my customers are with me
Just learn Spanish full of duelingo
Because I I don't even know what Noel Miller is. I'm like, is he Asian?
Is he Spanish?
Is he something else? Is he just white?
In the end I'm just a go
I'm sorry if that breaks your immersion
I
Apologize I know some people don't like to hear about this sort of stuff
But I'm an honest person and I like to talk and I like to yeah
so
And then you would have fucking found out anyways when you see my tan ass hand
On a hand cam stream
Or my legs on a thigh cam stream. You're like Leonardo DiCaprio point. What the fuck is that?
I
Do have bunny ears though
I genuinely have bunny ears
Don't don't forget that like I actually have bunny ears. I was born with a deformity. I don't like to talk about it
I do have bunny ears. Um, I don't have human ears. I just have bunny ears. Yep
It's fine youtube just tends to add a lighter filter. That's actually true though. Um
When I was streaming on twitch and I did my first hand cam doing like kind of the cooking popping the popping cooking that like emmy did
My hands look so fucking white on
Twitch from my webcam the people were like
Why the fuck are you talking about being proud and I'm like, no this saturation was down the lighting was bad. I'm telling you
I haven't been outside
In many moons
I changed colors. I'm a fucking chameleon
Sure
My white mother laughs at me in the daily because she's darker than me right now
Uh, yes, I am working on getting a tan toggle for my avatar for my avatar for me. What the fuck am I saying?
This isn't avatar the last airbender or the blue people. Um
My vitamin D deficient. Yes. Yes, I am
Give me some of that D
Sunny D. Unleash the power of the sun. Am I right?
Well, no, it'll be a toggle. I'm gonna I'm gonna be pulling an iron mouse. I've already said that
Pulling an iron mouse. I'm gonna be
She be cotton bum and she be codder copper bum
Instead of copper cat
Uh
Yes, is it me streaming today? I haven't looked at the fucking schedule
Long in
Is it? No, she's not streaming today. Okay
No, I'll stream a little bit past my time so we can actually get to game
Is there in two hours? Okay, I'll probably I'll stream into a zero then
Any relation to Rodney copper? No
I'm canonically related to every bunny character
however
Distant related to mr. Hopps and lola bunny
Jessica rabbit
And all other bunny vtubers also fall under that sphere
The auto cast fashion one at some point
If only there was a combined schedules for other girls that we can see well, we have our own little thing for that
I just looked at it
Uh, you guys can make your own
I don't know I think um
My son is working on updating the website. So it does show like all of our schedules. That would actually be really cool
Bonnie from fennel. Yes, big chunkus is a cousin of mine
Jessica rabbit was just her married name. Uh, yeah, I'm because I'm I'm related to Roger rabbit
And um, Jessica is related to me by marriage. Yep
Low punny is my first cousin once no
No
This is not alabama
But bugs bunny and yeah, they're related to me
related to jojo rabbit
I actually watched them a movie the other day. It was it was pretty actually fucking funny. I love uh taiko watidi
I didn't finish it though. I think it fell asleep
You can see the resemblance mean yeah, although how do we have resemblance if she's she's related to me by marriage guys
Related to peter rabbit
he's a
Any any like anthropomorphic bunnies like low punny because she's like a pokemon
But she doesn't have like sentience like a human like bugs does they are not really though. They are
Extremely distant extremely distant, you know
Okay, is it funny or is it boring that you fell asleep midway? No, I just felt I was just up really late
And I just sometimes you know how you like put something on to like fall asleep too
Or just to like to listen to I was like really into like the first half
I literally like I think 30 minutes or 40 minutes to finish
I
Yes, I do have um acme powers and my acme powers. It means I can uh inflate flatten out
Um do a lot of different things
Just like you know how bugs bunny does in cartoons and roger rabbit. I am
I do have tune powers. I do have tune powers. Yep
So basically love exactly just like lucky tune for you exactly. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. No
No inflation
None of that. No, no, none of that inflation cake, please
Gb Chungus does paint thinner kill you it hurts
A little like a burns all it's like we're like when you when you stick your hand on a hot stove, but it won't kill me
Do not call sonic I wasn't planning on googling sonic inflation
It's too late. You're canonizing. I am I can retcon it too
I can retcon it too, bitch
It won't kill you but this is mean you'll enjoy it exactly inflation and this economy
Cartoon versus anime jeans exactly because like I have my anime jeans and I have my cartoon jeans
you know
Who are my parents? I don't know
I'll be honest to you. I don't know who my parents are my rtx parents. They're pretty cool
But my uh 2d parents. I don't really know too much about them
It might one might be, you know
One might be just like I don't like there is a family rumor
I kind of try to ignore it that jessica rabbit is my mom and that she cheated on roger with uh bugs
Or it's like lola cheated on bugs with roger. I don't know the truth of that
so I try not to worry about it too much because
You know, I'm not trying to I don't need I already have like a familial relationship with them
I don't want to fuck it up. You know, I don't want to make it weird by being like, oh like taking paternity tests and all that shit, you know
What the fuck am I on right now?
You know, it's just like no weird family stuff
A weird family stuff. Yeah, or lola cheated on bugs. I don't know. I don't know how that works
There was a rumor that you know
Aunt Jessica was packing
I don't know
Okay, we're crazy the chat for 14 of my immortal
Random lord. Oh, yeah, what the fuck was I doing?
I am playing a game. I literally just talked for two hours
What the fuck?
I didn't even play the fucking game. All right
Uh, I need a sip of tea
Jessica rabbit canonically rugged goof. What?
It's yeah retract that message. What the fuck is that?
There is I should play there is no game like that one and then just like just talk the other time
Because there's no game because I'm just talking
Uh
The customer who looked tired you came. Yeah, I did
That's right. The customer who came. I mean who's a little tired
I'm here right after waking up
It makes me happy
Oh, are you feeling nervous? Is this
Why are the dudes in the back fucking unlockable characters?
Is this your first time at a place like this
Is that is this is that guy over there? Okay, like he doesn't have a face. Don't worry about it
Uh, okay. Well, that's right. I've never been here
I see. Well, then I guess I'll give you a brief explanation on how it works
Because you haven't started the fucking game yet. It's been two hours
Love the dude bro voice to give the main character
Please I don't know anything so this will help
The name of the shop is bunny garden a fun place to drink
We're run. We're owned by wonderland enterprises. The ceo is she be
Shut the fuck up. You can't say our name or forget the pit. Okay. Sorry
Never mind one of the girls said I can't talk about it. That's all
Oh, uh, seems like I should understand but I don't
Well, you'll gradually get used to it. So it's okay. I'll be really happy if you come here lots of times
You'll come here
Lots of times. Won't you?
You'll come
Here in my bunny garden lots of times, right?
Anyways
I agree to do that. I have to work hard at my current job because I have to take responsibility
Well, then I want you to be able to do your best. So I hope I can give you a lot of healing
Drop your pants
This isn't really good tea, I'm sorry, I choked a little bit a moment ago. So sorry
Oh
Okay
What's commenced
If I feel if I work harder
My dick is hard. I'll feel better. Why did you say don't worry about it? It's decided
Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't hear your order
Here you are. This is the menu
Right, maybe you'll have a drink
You guys got
Wait, what's
I see nade and she be nade
And emmy nade and azura nade
And mercy nade and stronti nade
It's in a section called lemon nades like
Can you elaborate?
It just said it just says in the description fresh from the source like what does that mean?
Sorry, I can't elaborate on the drink menu. You'll have to talk to my superior
Okay, uh, I guess I'll just have a normal drink then
What drink did you want?
Uh, pricey or drink could increase a pricey or drink can increase my likability with the fuck
Uh
Can I I don't have to use my arrows. Where's the sound? Oh my headphones are turned off
I
Feel like it if you spend a bag
Um
Oh wait, I have to use these which are the most expensive drink on the menu
Jesus fuck
You
Bunny trap
I'll take the house lemon sour
Oh, so the emmy nade
Yeah, whatever
I want to drink something too
I have to buy you a drink
Is this what?
Like bars are like like some bars are in japan because like I've never been to like a maid cafe or like any of that stuff again. I'm very
I don't have a sort of thing in america
Cabaret bars it's a hostess club. Yeah, we don't have those around
That's really actually I'm like thinking I'm like wait, it'd be a good job. It's like hooters except they buy you drinks
If you don't drink them to drinks, they will pour what if one of the girls gets fucking shit-faced
Because if you're like hanging out and drinking with people all the time
Like if like you have five customers and they just keep buying you drinks
Like are you limited to like one customer or like what is how does what's the I need an explanation here?
Actually, yeah, I remember someone said they were like trying to make a vtuber hostess bar that would actually be really fucking cool
Like do like hologram Miku
Except make it a vtuber 3d model
And I will gladly sit and have a drink with you and then I'll probably die because I can't handle. I'll call that will
um
I'll buy you some a special highball
Actually, you're a nice lady. I'm gonna buy you a fine wine
Oh, this is great. I love this
Whoa, uh, hello
I can zoom
I
Can get give them presents holy shit
So being a host a hostess bar is literally like
Being a girlfriend in a hoe without the sex and you just got to be nice to people
I would be so fucking good at that
Because like I have a very nice and charismatic personality
Just saying look it. There's a couple of you guys here. Hmm
It means you like me. He he
Gfe for a night
Fendom but with interaction
No, because like
Fendom like that. Usually the doms only take they don't give
Velvet queen tipped 127 dollars
Oh
Thank you velvet queen
Absolute mad lad velvet queen with the 127
What the
I'm really talking about
I'm looking I'm getting panty shots and people are giving me a hundred bucks. What's wrong with it? There's something wrong with this picture
Thank you. Thank you so much. I'm doing a little heart. I'm doing a little heart little signing. Yay for you
They bought me a drink. It was a very expensive drink. Thank you
Uh
How do I zoom
I'm like fucking uh, uh, I can't even remember the meme. I just want to zoom
Uh, it's chat. Did you even tell me your name? I'm getting kind of nervous
I mean, it's going to be the first time I meet this next customer
My heart
You know, I'm right here right like I can hear everything you're saying out lab
My heart feels like it's going to explode from how fast is racing. Why are you ignoring me?
Oh, what am I saying? The purpose of this place is to make customers feel relaxed not stressed
Yeah, but you're stressing me out because you're acting fucking crazy talking to yourself
If I'm in a state like this, I'm sure the customer is going to feel the same. Come on now. You've got this
Bitch, what the fuck are you on?
Sorry, I'm schizophrenic. Okay. Let's start off with the reasonable. Huh?
The first step in the order is to become friends. You're the customer. So please go right ahead with everything you've got
You can't see what I'm doing. So I'm taking my arm
I'm throwing it over my shoulder. I'm throwing it in front of myself like I have a giant cock
That's my first step
You like what you see
Huh
I mean
She said hit show me what you got so I showed her what I got
You know, you're fine. Don't worry about it
I hurt my elbow. Um, oh my god
She's my words carefully
A little bit of hug
What no hug there's a dude at my job that would do that and I fucking hated him
He'd be like, where's my hug? I'm like non-existent. I'm sorry. A customer is calling. Bye. Like
I'm sorry. If you do that to girls, you're fucking annoying
Where my hug at?
And then sometimes
Because like for me so I have OCD and certain like
feelings and like pressure
and textures
Maybe I'm just autistic. Um
Really bother me. I don't like to be hugged too much unless I really like like you or feel like a really close
family member or family friend or my parents
Like I literally will only let like
Salem and olive
And my parents hug me and my family members
Well, like when like because I'll say like people are like really touchy feely
And like I don't know like I'm just not like that
um
Yeah, I'm sorry physical touch is not my love language naturally as a dom. It's it's acts of service
So get on your knees and eat this kushi kuchi. Um
Um
Madam desires service
I need a bell. I need a bell to ring. Do I have a bell? I know I have a fucking bell
Well, it's not a bell actually it's I think it's my candle snuffer
Snuffing see where it is
But it like sounds like a bell
Oh, it's not dinging
Usually makes a ding noise
Damn it
Madam requires dick
Dick act as once just imagine bell noises. Okay. Thank you
Hmm
Or kuchi we don't discriminate in this household, okay
So a toast or something
That's what I just fucking said
That's the spirit you seem eager to start drinking but don't you think sharing each other's names comes first?
Well by the little bar that's next to your body. I can kind of surmise your name is kana or kana or
Can I eat your pussy out tonight?
What?
Never mind
Anyways, I'd love to know more about you
Right. My name is haito kana. Yeah kanda
I will butcher butcher japanese names. I apologize to my japanese friends
The vod staying up
relax the vod staying up
relax, oh
I just remembered because I just see I see someone with ochi marks in their name that aren't mine
Fuck you first of all, but I don't really blame you because um
My ochi marks don't work
on youtube so
We're gonna do a quick tangent when I say quick. I mean 30 minutes
um
I was gonna suggest that we pick some that are youtube friendly
The shit we're missing every free guy interaction see that um
Only 30 that's optimistic. Hey, hey
Slow your fucking roll kid. Okay. Don't disrespect me in my own households
Arobin, but yeah, but yeah, I know mercies don't like mercies scissors don't work
So I'm your vote is a snail in a tongue
Yeah, I see yeah polar bear doesn't work
But like bear and ice cube makes sense that works. Oh
Since the bunny works I will be bold and suggest the heel and the other bunny
But the bunny doesn't work
Is it the bunny face because the bunny like body doesn't work
But like try to put the because like you know like you look at my um
Um my old videos I had the rope in the bunny in my title. I might have taken it out actually
They don't show up. They just show up as squares
So I think the bunny head would work and then the high-heeled shoe would work
Bunny twins in an act
That's just the shining
No, it was the it was the it's the the bunny with the body and the rope they both don't work
Is it device to shoot? No
Because that's the second one you posted nugget isn't an emote actually like a like a normal emo. I don't think
Okay, here let's let's do this together
I'll put some in your fucking name then we'll see
What a fitting game all right now I have to pick them
Yeah, can you even test the working chat? Yeah, looks like see the working chat
But if you put them in your name doesn't work
Oshie mark can just be the membership icon. You mean the gimp bunny? I don't
No
No, but no I want Oshie marks. I'm not settling
A bunny in vomit
You fall for that a bunny and a knife. I'm not I would say probably a heart and a knife for mercy
I'm gonna say
The gunny if you will is there there's only a pistol. I wish I wish they had like this water pistol
I wish they had the old gun
I use this account for normal stuff though
Well, that's too fucking bad
I'm not changing my Oshie marks like this is the only specific to actually, you know what?
Until membership's open if you want to show your support and show that you're a harem member
You can put just the red high-heeled shoe in your name
So I don't think anybody uses that
I said yeah, the red high-heeled shoe would be cool
Because I think there's the red high-heel shoe works
And then like some bunny doesn't even that can just be anybody
Yeah, yeah
Yeah bunny head red heel pig
Yeah, whatever fucking one works, but just the red heel definitely because that one's obvious
Some body what's told me a rat
That would be more in me she got rats
Yeah, so you can do you can do a heel and whatever your heart desires
What's an Oshie mark? I like to explain it as imagine. It's a cutie mark
Of your favorite vtuber, but what's a cutie mark?
It's a little symbol that shows aspects of the pony's personality
For example twilight sparkle. She's purplish like twilight and there's a sparkler name. So it's like a purply sparkle sparkle on her punch
I've always said that Oshie marks are just cutie marks
Did you put a red heel in a pregnant man?
That was good. That was fucking good. They got me
Hmm so pop rocks to eat
I'm
Boomi's looking at me like what the fuck are you doing?
Good night
No, there's this I think there's a setting just to like put it in your name like your display name
Only if you want to
Oh, look at you guys with your bunny heel. Oh, it makes me happy
Oh my god, that makes me so happy
I'll I'll add it to my description
Like if you want to show your support
Here are the youtube Oshie marks and I'll just put like the bunny in the heel
He'll in a nose
Cool
My day is made
Bro, I was so productive today. I went to the doctor's office
I paid some bills. I still haven't done my dishes
I picked up my mail my packages. I'm streaming
I got lunch
I'm feeling good today. I napped for 30 minutes. It was more like 15
These pop rocks are so fucking good
I'm adulting
Can you play the game now, please? Can you please play the game?
Shabby shabby, shut the fuck up
The big kids are talking the big kids the adults are talk
I just choked in a pop almost a pop socket pop rock
Suck my left titty anyways
You don't need to keep looking at me like that. There's a k pop rocks are awful
Nobody asked
Did anyone ask what is that? Oh, nobody asked. That's crazy. Anyways
I'm more of a writing F
You don't need to keep looking at me like that
Oh, sorry. I wanted to remember your name and face you see
So well, I look like the other two guys in this place. I'm just
a black void
If yeah, I know but you know
There's no need to worry. I've matched your face to your name now, but I look I'm an unlockable character
Okay, it's my turn now
All right, my name's conna. I don't mind if you give me a nickname, but I sure you hope to
Yeah
All right, I'll call you conty
Because you're con you talk to yourself a lot
I'll do my best to match your name to your face then conna chan. Yeah
Gonna come on her chin. What was that? Oh, so conna chan
Hey, stop it. You're making me all flustered
I I didn't know it felt this embarrassing to be stared at. Well, you got massive fucking jugs
so
I suppose there's some things you learn from firsthand experience
Yep, I guess I got a little smarter from this whole situation
What are you talking about? Well, tell me more about yourself. Hi to come
I messed up real bad at work recently and because of that the boss fired me
So I've been assisting a friend. It is I wonder what you did for his job. Like, what did he fuck up?
If you ever knew a compilation of streams this will definitely make it
It's more like you're not you're cleaning and not making more dirty dishes to clean dishes up. Yeah, it's because like I had dishes and dishwasher
I still need to take them out and put the other dishes away and then put the new ones in the dishwasher
So someone's sandwich probably forgot to use MLA format. That's what I'm going with
I need more
My god, I really like the like
like the
Stuff coming from the ceiling that the uh all the drinks are on that's actually really fucking cool like the
The place in here is pretty sick
Oh, that sounds rough
Anyways, want to buy me another drink?
If I was in your shoes, I probably wouldn't even be able to eat
You should just kill yourself
I
What uh, though, I sorry. I meant to say though. I'm sure words can't express how awful you must feel. I'm so sorry
Did you just tell me to kill me? No
Silly
All right. I got it
I'm going to do my absolute best in order for you to get back on your feet
What the fuck are you gonna do? Are you gonna give me a job?
Oh
The time you spend here will be I'm gonna ignore that the time you spend here will be a constant smile
I can assure you that much
I hope we get a long haitoku
Can you keep drinking haitoku?
Don't push yourself. Okay. I have like five other guys. I need to hang out with
And we're gonna get some burgers and fries later
I can't should I keep talking to her
I
This game sucks, dude
No, no, that's funny. Okay
Wow, is it already this late? I'll head back home
Jesus fuck
Thank you for today. See you soon
Yeah, thanks for everything. See you soon
Mom dad have a girlfriend. Yeah, she works at a hostess bar and her pay like 4500 yen to see her
But she's really sweet. She gives me great your life advice
I could talk to my cat for free
Save the risen for others. Okay, I got you
It was such a nice place and the customer service was great. Maybe I'll go there for the time being
Oh
Sick
Do I need oh
Okay, cool
I can spend six kyan on socks
Yeah, I'm buying girl socks and then I'm gonna make her wear them and then give them back to me
Duh
I'm gonna never fucking socks
All right, let's calendar make a girl out to dinner first. Oh
Yeah
Ninka doggy tipped six dollars and 90 cents your little additions to the dialogue are killing me. I love it
I have a
I have like really bad because when I watch movies I do this too
Uh, I really bad impulse like to say stupid shit during a movie or like a tv show that I'm watching
and
I do it a lot and I'm like, I remember thinking and like also when I play games
And then like seeing that people like did that on like with first streamers and for youtube
I'm like, why the fuck don't I become a street like I do this on the daily
I do this to my like I just talked to my cats. I streamed for my cats
All of them I can sleep
I can go on vacation
Does that are we fucking on vacation?
Why aren't there only three girls?
Two of them look the same
They're they're dressed like they're
Bunny power rangers I just
pterodactyl tyrannosaurus
I never get the fucking blue one
I
Massed it on there's a mass it on
What are you time for? Oh
Triceratops, yeah, the leaders from pokemon go
This one's me
Me with ponytails. Uh, this one
Is
None of the girls in our group look like that. Uh, this is emmy because they have the same pigtails
No, I wouldn't not never mind. That's not that's not none of these girls are us because
I've been making some if this was emmy I'd be making serious saver some really stupid
Although telling someone to kill themselves is very on character for her
How's it going? How is the stream?
My sweet sweet you may plus girls my sweet girls
So so cute so silly guys, please check out uh you may plus and um
The girls because they are
Mosa is unhinged just like me
Trying to give me her lotion tend to see there you go
They're such cute girls. I like I'm honestly surprised they're not like
Fucking ginormous
It should be I love watching their stream. They don't know but I creep on their streams
And I like to giggle at them a lot. He he I just work
Help
Yeah, yeah, I'm watching you
I'm watching you mimosa. I'm gonna drink you like a mimosa. Okay. Anyways, let's gamble
I'm gamble up to 10 times if I was a true gambler. I would have no limit
I'm leaving
Okay, I'm staying
Yeah, pull up a chair pull up a chair baby girl
Pull up a chair baby girl come hang out in my bunny garden. Yeah
Uh, can we play blackjack?
What the hell is this? Is this a skull king from inscription gambling?
Wait
I don't even fucking play a game. I just lose money
Are you serious? I'm never fucking using this again. Why would I ever get what is the point?
Now I have less money
But like I wish I thought there'd be like a cute minigame where I play like blackjack or like poker or like
Fucking solitaire. I don't know
What the hell man, I've been cheated
You can save scum till you win. No, I'm not gonna do that
I was almost 20 bucks
Let's do it again
Can I like can I just like skip ahead? I don't care about this fucking splash screen
No
No, I'll see you again
This is 31 k yen
Run it back run it back run me my oh fuck. I lost again
Okay, no
This sucks
Just keep fucking you guys are like, I love this game
No, I don't
Feel they're going to debt
I remember I went to a casino with $50 and I lost it all and I cried it was only $50
It wasn't even my $50. It was my it was olives because we were uh celebrating that she got a gig in an acting thing
She was her friends to casino and I'm but I was like I was just like broke because like
I had like a lot of health bills and shit and so she's like gave me 50 bucks and I was like
And I was like, I'm gonna flip this and give you your 50 bucks back. I lost it
I will never gamble that shit is terrible
Well, hello there
Obi-Wan Kenobi
Yes
Thanks for visiting me today. I don't want to talk to you
Can I talk to one of the other girls
Can I just buy you a drink give me a gin and tonic
Yeah
Can I have some too? No, bitch. I'm broke
fine
Buy you some water with ice. How about that?
You're getting less in me you're getting this whatever the fuck this is
Pay some music. Okay. You don't have to relax. Okay. Keep your panties on turn around. Oh
Oh
What
Are you serious?
If I don't buy I swap girl
Damn
Uh, well, I don't want to give my present to you
Because I don't know why but you kind of just bother me and your boobs are like breathing
How does that even work?
I like I'm breathing right now. I'm looking down on my boobs
My boobs don't separate and have breath in life of their own
This isn't working their boobs have lungs, you know, I don't breathe
She's got a bigger chest my chest is as big as hers. I'm not even fucking joking
Her brain is there too when I go for a jog my tit punches me in the face
Okay
Proof well proof
Boom there's your proof
There's your proof anyways cut the music put it back on
Uh, there's food
Oh
Uh, I haven't eaten in a couple days. Uh, do you want some edamememe?
Uh
Huh, what's wrong you seem puzzled
It just seems like you're a broke-ass bitch and you only got edamame. So like why couldn't you've gotten me like sushi or something?
Huh
Got it
I took you're hi took. Wow
You forgot my name
Yeah, so that's what you got you forgot my name was trying desperately to remember it
That's not I hate I don't like you
I don't like you
Give me another girl
Customer service here sucks
Can I speak to your can I speak to your manager bring me the manager bring me the fucking manager
I
I want to be a dick can I be a dick and just say hi. I'm kind of no because then she's just gonna remember my name wrong
Well, I'm never gonna talk to her again. So actually I'm kaito
Oh, I was one letter off
Uh, I mean sorry about that. Mm-hmm. Where are you giggling? Wait, you tricked me
Anyways dick don't worry about me. I'll never forget your name anymore. So don't worry. Okay too late
I am wanting to talk to the girl in blue. So hurry up
Thanks, but no thanks. Uh, I'm really sure it's hard for you to remember every customer's name like that
Yeah
Guys kind of all look the same like unlockable characters and I wish you had name tags or something
You know something cute like what you see a kindergartner wearing
Sorry
I'm only joking of course
I'm a lollicon. I'm a pro in my field
Remembering names is my specialty
All you do
Well, you did seem to remember my name within seconds before seems like you're doing great for my eyes
Weird you don't have any. Yeah, I know
Oh, thanks. You really are kind. Aren't you hi toku?
It's kaito
Like the vocaloid
I'll make sure to never forget your name
Hi toku should I get more drinks? I want to keep talking to you more
That's a no for me dog
When did it get so late? I guess I'll head back soon
Thank you for today. You're fucking broke. See you soon. You can't buy anything
Yeah, thanks for everything. See you soon
We're so poor
Can you get kicked out of bunny garden? That would actually be really funny
Yeah, I got paid that's fucking
I got paid
You know what time it is
Let's fucking go
With eyes only one eye is glowing
It's white
Let's fucking go let's fucking go
I'm buying you all drinks the whole garden gets drinks. What do you want?
No
We're so back bros so fucking back
So fucking back 90% of gamblers quit before hitting it big
Shut up
Boy tipped one dollar. Thanks boy. When do we start gardening?
Uh
I came up with a really bad joke
I'm gonna say it anyways. Um, so I'm gonna need your mom to come over
Uh, and I'm gonna trim her hedge. All I'm gonna say all I'm gonna say
Uh
Wow games so fun
Oh
Cast members may be away in Saturdays. Yes
Okay, what what what voice what voice for her? What voice? He's kind of gyaru. Should we give her a valley accent?
After we plant the seed exactly exactly this guy fucking gets it happy happy valley girl. Okay
Hi, what drink did you want?
Uh, you're hot as fuck. I'm gonna get you something nice. I'm gonna treat you
Sorry, it's like my keyboard
I just won big at gambling. So I'm gonna have
A bunny trap
Because I like traps. What was that? Don't worry about it
Okay, whatever
Can I have some too? Yeah, I got you baby girl
I'm gonna get you the bunny punch because I'm gonna punch your fart box with my tongue later
Huh, don't worry about it
I'm sorry
I
Want to tongue punch your fart box
Man
Because I'm gonna just like make clips of just this one
this one, uh
I'm just like all the dumb ass I'm saying
Uh, hold on take a sip
I was in your tea, it's literally only chamomile
in mint
In lavender. I'm eating. I'm drinking the sleepy time tea
Uh, that you lovely bitches got me off throne. Thank you so much. It's my favorite tea
Usually I take it to fall asleep
But I don't feel like taking the throat coat for my throat because I've been talking this entire week in last week
So I'm drinking this instead. It's very tasty. It's not caffeinated
How am I holding up? I'm holding up good. I'm having a great time
I can take a shot. You guys want me should we take a shot?
You guys want to take a shot? You guys want to take a shot? I got Tito's
Should we get Lady Titty? Should we make this a drunk stream?
Sounds good. Take a shot. Take a shot part in a jar. What?
Just shot of Tito's. I don't have a lime to chase it though
Let's do it. Let's fucking do it. Oh my god, Rina. I was rolled over you. Hi. What's up? Can I help you?
Hey
Oh, what's up?
Hey mama's how you doing? Oh, why are you wet?
Her chest is wet because she sometimes like sticks her whole entire fucking body into the water bowl a water fountain
Here you want some cat purrs? Oh, let me switch off the desktop audio so you can hear her purring
Cat purrs and shots
Oh
That's my big mama
You trying to stop me from taking a shot because you're not gonna Rina
Anyways, um, let me just get up and be worse for you
I just thought of that uh that side talk. Do you remember like the um
Being gone guy like the same side talk guys
I just think of that fucking the black dude on the street. It's like talking to a homeless chick
He's like you want a shot? You want a shot? You want a shot?
Ah, I fucking love that clip. So funny buddy. Oh my god
Uh, do I have a shot glass?
I only got a little bit of
You
We drinking straight from the bottle bros because I don't
You want a shot you want a shot drink from my ocey mark like my shoe
It is just Tito's vodka
80 proof 40% alcohol
Oh
Dear lord heaven, we are so baraco bono. Hello baraco, bubba
You want a shot you want a shot? I want you to look up that clip right now and picture me
saying that to you
And that you know like that um
That like pennywise the clown
When he takes a he's about to take a drink of something and he just like flicks the cap off
I can't do it. Oh, it's perfect. Oh shit. I dropped it and then he just swigs it. That's what i'm gonna do
Oh my god, that tangled my fucking nipples what the fuck
Oh
You want a shot you want a shot? Oh, I need a moment
Fuck yeah
Oh, aren't you funny?
Charlie spurred it four dollars and 20 cents. Thank you charlie. Madam. I offer all my worldly possessions to you smiling face
All right, can I have your clothes?
Give me your shoes. I like your shoes. Are we the same size?
Yeah, I'll take those two. Thank you. Appreciate it. Thank you charlie
Oh, I'm gonna sleep well tonight
You want a shot you want a shot?
You want a shot?
Oh, that was a Tito's burp
Can I have your clothes in return? No
I own you
I own you okay
in your mouth
Almost I fucking love you
Most reveal bunch match up my energy right now
That's what I was referencing I was referencing side talk
You can't pull out the gun every time you drink who fucking said I can't I do what I want when I want it
I'm now eating applesauce
I'm eating it go go squeeze
If you're gonna drink with me make sure you hydrate and eat something
This is America
Don't get you stripping on stripping. I don't fucking talking about I'm so happy
because
Today I discovered when I was listening to the new Caitranata album that challenged Gambino and Caitranata
made a fucking song together and I've been I literally was praying
To the gods above in the universe for that and it happened and it was great
And then they did a pink pantherist and I was like, holy
Best side talk vid
Hmm
Baby a triple
Anonymous tipped three dollars and 33 cents. He said face red heart shape
Baby
Um, I think probably
Okay, no pray for me to be debt-free
Pray I'll pray for all of us. I'm praying
Oh universe
Oh gods above, please. Let us all be debt-free
Please let us all win the lottery. Thank you
Inshallah
God willing
I fucking love pink panthers
Amen
And so it shall be and so it might be
I forget the Hebrew way to say amen or is that is amen already Hebrew? I don't know
That is a prison and gambling is the key time to gamble
Pray that tax, pray that taxes are abolished. No taxes. Actually, no tax are rich
All right, take another swig hold on
Any music any music any just like any music for a second
I mean, I don't know. Sorry. I'm gonna be uh, which will goes for a second
I get claimed but I only do a couple seconds
I'm doing it from my phone
Yeah
Where the cap though
Hold on
Wait, no
Okay, we're good. How do I see how I do this
Okay, find the cat no cat go away girl go
I'm scared. Did you just what the fuck it? What do you mean? What the fuck is going on?
What?
Okay, I took two swigs of my Tito's I'm feeling a horn
Here's a present. I just met you but this is crazy
Here's some socks. So wear them maybe
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this? I just want you to like it
Please wear them
There's something I'm gonna buy you wonder where next
I got something good
Wait, wait, hold on wait a sec. You're pretty cute. But why are you curled up in a ball, sir
How the fuck if I curled up a ball in a ball at the fucking counter, but okay
What's wrong?
You must be nervous. That's no good getting nervous over me is just a waste of energy
Oh, hello, my name is Hito Kanda. It's a pleasure to make your acquaintance
That's disgusting
Don't burp in my face again
You started introducing yourself. You fucking weirdo
Well, then I will too
Hello, I am Rin. Sorry to trouble you. What am I doing? Is this how it's supposed to go?
So what do you do hi Chan calling how she calls me Chan?
Um, well right now I'm an assisting and acquaintance with their job
But until recently
Charlie spurting Charlie dollars and 20 cents. It's too late. I wear an eye patch
L and my medical bills are astronomical. I think the prayer is too late
Jesus fuck
I'm sorry. I hope I hope that can be recovered for you
So far
Uh
Uh, stop. Yeah, stop the fucking
Are you a toxic or a pirate bro? You're so fucking out of pocket for that
Honestly, uh eye patches are badass though
Like there's like this one like governor. I think of in america that was a former, um
It's like a military veteran
And he wears an eye patch and he looks fucking cool and you can pretend you're solid snake sometimes
so
That's good. I hope it goes well
Thank you for the the tip
Let me just scratch my nose
But until recently I was implanted company. However, do you know a plethora of mistakes? I was terminated
Is there even a word for plethora in japanese?
Hang on hi tan. I can't keep up with all that formal speech stopping a fucking weirdo
I'd be super grateful if you could just like talk normally
It's like what is this?
I'm moving my hands around you can't tell
Yes, it's called plethora
Oh really, I'll drop the pretenses then
Thank you. You're such a nice guy. Hi chum
Even if you're too formal and weird sometimes it's their loss for firing you you're better off without them
No, they treated me pretty well, but I'm kidding by okay now
I won the gamble the other day and I did well
Wow, you're really something hi tan. You don't badmouth them even after getting fired. I respect that
You know you're for real for real
No cap facts. No printer ink. What the fuck did you just say?
You're a stand-up guy. You must get that a lot, huh?
I don't get that at all they do let me hear some more
Let me hear some more. I need you to feed can you feed my ego?
You feed my ego, please
You're such a kind upstanding person. Hi chan. It's true. I just met you. We've only talked once
You're really kind of fucking weird, but sure. You know, you are so kind
in upstanding
I already said that
You already said that. Yeah, but you're kind and upstanding. Okay
Oh, hey, let me tell you something. I'm serious. Well, I'm always serious, but I'm seriously
serious
Are you okay?
Meeting new people is really important right in life. I mean online, you know
So I'm really grateful to have met you hi chan
And maybe far from perfect, but I'll still do the very best I can
Hope you're ready
I'm gonna sit on your face
Oh, what?
Um, sorry. I didn't mean to say that ellipses
How embarrassing what am I saying sit on your face?
That was so forward of me. Um, well you get the idea. Did you catch all that? I'm not saying it again
I'm gonna sit on your face
By the way, the other girls here will also sit on your face and they're really nice too. I think you'll like this shop a lot
If you find that I'm not your type after talking to me a few times feel free to slide
Up to the next row and set or you can have us both at once
I'm not the type of girl who's bothered by that sort of thing to be you know
With another girl and a guy I'm I'm bi, you know
I'm pretty fluid
I don't believe in labels actually
Uh, can you can we change the subject fine?
Well on the other hand if you do find that I'm your type it'd make me pretty happy
Uh, well, I'll leave it at that
So like do you want to have a threesome or?
Uh, I I didn't pay for that kind of service
It's on the house. Just say fucking yes. I don't think I'm comfortable with that
I'm sorry
Um, anyways, I look forward to serving you or whatever. I guess don't fucking threesome with me and the girl in the blue
bitch
Bet you watch his
Worst head tie
What did you say?
I can't how about drinks? Do you want a bit more? Should I get you something?
Uh, no, I'm good
When did it get so late? I should head back soon
I don't know
If you can please the cast members in the shop
I'm gonna leave my eyebrows
They'll see you out in a good mood when you leave
Hito who is sent off is more motivated to work and hat
What the fuck?
Thank you for today. See you soon
Yeah, thank you for today. So about that threesome. So I'm meeting the other girl like in like an hour
Did you want to like I gotta get home? I have work tomorrow, but it's sunday. Uh, yeah
over time
later
Irina
I don't know if you guys heard her meow she went
She's in my lap
You know
I got to drink some delicious alcohol and have fun conversations now motivated for work
Um
Okay, I don't know what the fuck that is let's buy another thing
I'm gonna buy some macarons for the blue black haired girl
Hmm
Now it's my time to rest up and recover. This is the only place that can heal my mind
Oh, fuck it's this bitch again, what? Oh you came thanks
and
Clean up after yourself next time. That's all I'm gonna say
Um, what drink did you want?
I don't want to hang out with you
can I like
Not buy anything because I don't want to talk to you. I'm gonna get a blueberry liquor
Because that sounds tasty
Can I have some too? No, bitch. I want to talk to the girl in blue
A
Customer called me so I better get going. No one else is fucking here
I get it. You're embarrassed. I want to talk to the blue girl
Can I she just fucking walked in place. No, I don't want to talk to you either
Let me talk to her
Okay, I'll just get some food
Oh damn this make me hungry. Maybe eat dinner
What is a Gio Ailo a Jillo
Oh
You want some cheese and crackers you want some salami I can give you a heart salami
um
Like no, thanks. All right fine. I guess we'll just be french fries
Thank god this tastes so good
Ha, I'm glad you came back. Thank you. Have you been good?
Yeah, you seem like you're in a good mood to wrench on
How do you know my name? I don't oh no, she did introduce herself. Never mind
girl dinner
When do you get the sushi off of her? Oh
So like
Is there gonna be an option on the menu where I can eat sushi off your body? Sorry. I hit the microphone
Um, we don't do that store to service here. This place fucking blows
Where's my happy ending?
What good would I be if I couldn't put on a smile? I'm ignoring that
Hmm
Yeah, my neighbors are walking by you actually don't look like you're feeling so great yourself
Really I'm feeling fine physically today and I don't have any problems
You look shitty. It's all I'm gonna say buddy. Did you shower?
You smell like you haven't showered
You sure nope, but you're definitely not feeling good
Not at all
This is a bad omen, you know
Get it today's fortune
You know would make the the bad omen go away if you buy me a better drink
Or some sushi
Or if you have that threesome I keep talking to you about you know, I never mind you smell bad
Me and girl in blue don't want to fuck you anyways
When does this she be real-time phantom stream
See Japanese honorifics and the F boy voice is so
Can I start saying thank yous. Oh my god, thank yous
But hey, sir, you're lucky. In fact, I can judge based on your name want to try
Oh, fuck. You're one of those numerology astrology bitches. Fuck crazy, bitch. What?
Sure
Like fortune telling with names
Sure, I'll give it a try
Okay. Okay. Um, I know your name already. You told me what it was last time, right?
Did you forget my fucking name and you're just
stalling for me to say it
Yeah, I introduced myself to you right. I know it. I know it. I know it. Um, but I need to know how it's
Well, let's see the fortune telling you are so full of shit
No, I'm not I pooped this morning
How do you spell your name in kanji?
I am haito it's con. Why would I just say my last name? Why would you say my filming name?
I could be an ass and say it's spelled in hiragana
Uh
I'll teaser
I want my birth chart
Like I don't want us free threesome bra. I'm like
Uber uncomfortable with that. Oh like I don't want a threesome bra
I'm like uber uncomfortable with that. I only do threesome with my bros
We Eiffel tower
Each other
Huh?
Nothing. It's kanda
Right, but what I want to know is your first name
I don't think I called you by your first name last time. You literally gave me a female honorific
because you're a bitch
First the characters for cup in person then dry in field. That's how you spell haito kanda. Remember now
You got me, huh? I totally forgot your name. I'm really sorry
Okay, I found a way online
I'm one of those
Oh my god, witch talk is so helpful to learn someone's name after you forget it
It's said to offer to tell their fortune with it clever, huh?
But how did you figure it out? Was it acting suspicious?
These girls are annoying me
You seem like the type of person who can't tell a lie french hand, but you kind of just technically lied by a mission
It was written all your face how you were acting
I get it people usually tell me they can read me like an open book
I live honestly. It's so tiring to cover up stuff with lies
It's easier just to be honest and then apologize when you get scolded
I'm sorry. Hi Chan. You told me your name, but I forgot it and then I tried to pull the wool over your eyes
I'm really sorry. So, um
What are you gonna do to make up for it?
What do you mean?
I'd like my happy ending, please. I'd like to order one happy ending
Get on your knees
Come on
No, I I I can't we're at work and I I'm asking politely
I know where you live
Oh, okay. Can I do it later?
Fine
Sorry, I got
I'm sorry. I forgot where I was. Haido just took over me. I don't even
I
Why would the bod be dead? Oh, aren't you funny?
Anonymous thank you and dollars and 20 cents appreciate you man
That's crazy even more money for the lovely madden she man. That's crazy
You want the type ending? I don't know. I know what it is
I don't think it was kaito. I said hi, though
I never thought I wanted to be in top of this game, but here we are
I can't tell if from the game what ship is in problem. I'm gonna actually watching
Stocker is I learned from mercy
Oh
Make myself a little bit bigger
There we go
Block that girl's ass you guys can't see only I can see
I
Scare you it's good. You should be scared. It's all right to bother me at all
For real. Yay. Well, then let's get back and have some fun
So lay back
I'll find on button your pants for you
Wow
That's really small. Hey, I'm just
It's just I'm not worked up yet. Okay. All right. Well
Here it goes
It's cold in here
Sir, it's it's heated to 73 degrees in here. You're sweating. Yeah, I will
That's really pathetic. All right, fuck you
I'm just gonna fuck it
Well, I'll go extra hard today to make up for my screw up with your names
I won't insult you anymore
You're still drinking. Hi Chan
Drinking to forget careful not to overdo it. Okay
Please someone get this guy out of here. His dick is so small
I'm leaving
Wow, it's already this way wipes tears from face. Oh, are you?
Charlie spur tipped four dollars and 20 thank you again Charlie. No, it's average size. I swear
Don't make fun of me madame. Loudly crying
Why are you guys so tiny? How's anybody supposed to work with that?
I'll head back home
Bigger when you pull on it
Thank you for today. I have to brush my teeth
Taste it like cigarettes. See you soon
Yeah, thanks for everything. Didn't even get to come. See you soon
Oh fuck
Oh, you know what this means
I wish this had more banger music. This is not a banger music guys
Okay, sometimes the eyes glow and sometimes they don't when it's red it means I lost. Oh fuck. Uh, we're gonna do it again
We got we got money to spend. Oh when it glows one eye, we win. I'm pretty sure and it turns white
Or not it does not oh, I did win. Yeah
Let's do it again
It's not more impressive when you measure in millimeters. I lost again
Oh
Baby a triple all baby a triple three dollars and thirty three cents. Thank you razz nuts
Just a tip. Thank you for the tip. Thank you for the tip
All right lost again
God damn it
I won
All right, I didn't win that much though
Okay, if you get the one red glowing eye and white screen you win big
But if you just get a no glowing eyes and white screen you kind of win a little bit
But if you get two glowing red eyes you lost badly and if you get
no glowing red eyes
Uh
You lost
Small amount one red glowing eyes lost like a medium amount. Okay
Oh baby a triple
Oh
She means just like me when the high of energy drinks longer does it. Oh my god. Fuck it makes me
I need to feel alive
I know I'm not gonna game the system. Fuck that
We're not gaming the system. I didn't read that. It's fine
No, I want to talk to the blue girl
Get these bitches out of my face
Oh, you came I'm glad I have to change my outfit now
What drink did you want?
What are you buying what are you selling uh, I'm feeling crazy
Can I have some too are we splitting it fine, I'll get you
I
Get you a highball
It tastes amazing. I love this
Well
Are you wearing the same panties girl change your underwear?
I'll give you the macarons. I guess
There you go
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this I swear I didn't put razors in them. I swear
Just don't look just close your eyes when you eat them. Uh, I hope you like it
Wow, thanks, I'll take care of
How those get in there
Why did you put razors in this
You good did nobody get my bit
They weren't paying attention. Um, you seem happy. Did something happen?
Did you guys think I actually hurt myself?
Well, you came all this way to oh, sorry
Frog at my throat. Uh, well, you came all this way to visit me. Hi token. Of course. I'm happy
Thanks, but you seem much happier than usual
I'm not I just swallowed a razor, but
We have medical concerns. I'll be okay
Um, maybe it's because I really got some time to relax during my time off recently
You used your days off to the fullest then
Did you go shopping?
I mostly shop online these days
I'm a neat except I need to go
To this job so I can make money
Because I like to play gotcha
Why are you telling me all this because you fucking asked?
Um, but sometimes going around different stores and looking at what they have makes me feel super excited
I played with my dog for the whole day less
Naughty naughty you teasing me naughty naughty
Oh you have a dog
Bro, oh hi mero
She plays blue archive
Hello, hello, mero my sweet little cute
I'll see your golden tree
Uh-huh. He's a chihuahua
He's a chihuahua hula called wawa. You mean a chihuahua. Yeah, whatever. He's super cute
And when you call him wawa chin, he waxes tail and comes to you when he sleeps. It's always next to me too
He loves walks too, so I take him to this really big park near my place whenever I get a day off
That's what we did last time too
So you just hang out with your dog? Yeah
That sounds great or whatever. I love dogs too
Really? Yeah, I have a husky golden retriever mix
That's fucked
Well, I hope you give wawa. Sorry. I hope you give wawa chin a nice pat if you ever come around
I'm sure you'll end up enjoying this company too. No
Oh, should you blame it on the alcohol?
We know her routine we can go mercy mode now. I know she's she's giving up a lot of information
Oh, no, no, no, no
It's where color is red. Oh my god
Do you think he'd be fine to run? Why are you?
This is the like the third
Time I've talked to you and you're like I need to meet my dog
Do you think he'd be fine around me though? I wonder if he'll think I was trying to take his master away from him
because
I have a question to ask you
Will you be my master?
Or my mistress?
What? Never mind
How are those socks?
You gave them to the other girl. Oh
Who knows
That could happen wawa chin loves me so much after all
You're trying to seal me away
Huh, what's wrong?
I'm just trying to buy your affections
Uh, nothing at all. I'm feeling a little sweaty right now. Actually
God, I wonder what's wrong with me
Oh, are you good? Sorry. It's my lush. I mean
You want a drink?
Uh, I think I'm good
Is your dog like chocolate?
Oh, she came and said hi to me
I'll be waiting for you. So please come again
Yeah, thank you for today
fucking weirdo
Like our boobs jiggle when she waves like your boot wait actually I'm waving my hand or my boobs jiggling
What's that buzzing noise? Don't worry about it
It's it's air conditioning. It's the ac
Okay, we had a good fun conversation. I'm looking forward to going to work now
Can I like what is this thing? Okay, I don't know what that means. Um, I'm sure it's safe. I'll save
Like how they dance in the corner
Um
Okay, there's not a lot to do in this game and it's kind of annoying
I'm like, uh, okay. So I get them gifts. I talk. Is that really it?
I don't think ac sounds like that. Don't worry about it
Come on. Give me white screen. Fuck
What should I lose? Oh
Oh, give me a red screen and I run
Okay
Okay, okay. My stride is totally wrong then usually I thought the thing would give an indicator, but it really doesn't
Bro, what the fuck
Oh
Okay, that's fine
No longer yippie
Uh, buy some perfume because I want to know what she smells like
And so I could buy the same perfume and we can I can spray it on my pillowcase and pretend I'm sleeping next to her
What should I drink today beer wine champagne? Let's just get in there first go
Sorry jumpscare
Please can I talk to the girl in blue?
Thanks for visiting me today, but I please talk to that bitch over there. It's all I want
She has a fatter ass than you. Um, okay. Well, what drink did you want?
Uh, I'm feeling spicy today
I'm gonna get the bunny max
Because I'm
Never mind
Can I have some too? No, you can't go away
Please please bring me her please. Oh, thank god
Finally
I guess the point is to lift the fantasy of having your life ruined by hostess club addiction
All right
One voice
One voice to you governor
Oh, I saw some applesauce left. I didn't even notice
Blue
Sporty tomboy
Mommy vibe smoker voice sexy as possible voice. She's very coup d'etre really
Nerdy voice mommy
Theater attitude is like first. Okay. We'll chat a little bit. I'm gonna give her a present
Actually, no, I'm not gonna give it her just yet. I'll give her I might extend my time with her
Because I've talked to them the most the other two girls
Want to get some food
Um
Let's get some whatever the fuck this is
I love this this is really delicious. I'm feeling all sorts of happiness
Oh, hello. Nice to meet you
Would you like to introduce yourself?
Oh, yeah, you may call me hi to kanda
Oh
You don't have to be polite with me
Oh, I see. I mean, okay. I'm hi to kanda. I helped my friend for work
I didn't ask that
You help your friends like
With a hand job
Yeah, I was working at a company up until recently but I messed up
It got fired
fired
right
Are you bad at holding conversation
Are you person of a few words?
I guess I don't speak much
Um hi to
Why do you sound like a fucking robot? Yeah
I'm oh, I just spilled apple sauce on my shirt
It's choked on it
I always hit my head on my mic. I'm falling apart
I'm sorry
You're kind of a loser
The guy is a charmer
What does that mean
I'm sorry. I'm like this. Maybe you won't be able to have a good time
It's okay. Who knows what will happen
You can sign my dick
I could suck your toes
You can suck my dick
Just met each other
So my dick
I think would be nice if you could suck my dick. Just take things slow, you know first base
Sucking my dick
No rush
We already started to get to know each other
Oh
Thank you
You're kind one. Hi, though
Do you want some alcohol?
What should I do? Is there anything I should prepare?
Yeah
My efforts have been rewarded. I want to drink something delicious
What drink did you want? I'm giving her like several different voices. I'm so sorry. I'm buying you
I don't have enough money. Uh
Well, okay, what drink do I want so I will have
I'll just have a beer
Where's the beer the fuck is the beer? I'll have a beer. I don't know why we have it in these glasses, but
Can I have a drink with you?
Yes, my beautiful princess. I'm gonna get you a bunny punch
Because I'm gonna punch my dick into your womb and fill you with children
I like that. All right
What that's it I expected more
Deep the deep Riz
S to your Riz. Thank you
Okay, I have a present for you
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this? I hope you like it
It smells like my mom
What don't worry about it
Okay, thanks
We have to take care of it
Take care of what?
Your dick
Huh?
What?
I keep doing double takes to see if this is the time
Oh
Why are they just staring at each other and quiet? Oh my god
Wait, wait, you buy a drink for the bartenders. Yes. Yes, you do
This is this is this is a good stream today
Is there anything you want to talk about? Yeah, uh, you think tomorrow be sunny or whatever
Um, there's a monsoon raging outside
I have no idea. I have no idea. I have no idea. I have no idea. I have no idea
Sorry
Buy a drink for the bartender to take a small sip and throw it into the plants. Oh, yeah
But like how do they pace themselves? You have to have like
quite
Like you have to be able to handle your liquor if you're serving patrons from let's say like
Let's say your shift is like five hours
And maybe you hang out with a guy for each hour
Like how many people are buying you more drinks? Is this happening? Like I need to know the schematics
Goofy
Do they really only take one sip?
I
Are all they're pretty good. No, like legit like tell me the tea is the tea piping hot cuz spill it
You don't drink with every patron. Okay. Do they actually puke constantly?
This is the equivalent of the ghost anime top. I love that fucking dumbest hilarious
It's basically they're tipping they mix it for themselves. They probably don't mix. Oh
Oh, that's true. I because I had a friend actually I don't had a friend. She does this currently olive
She bartends and she tells me sometimes customers try to buy her a drink and she just literally gives herself
Like a sprite and says it's a gin and tonic
Yeah, or they mix the drink of water
Excuse me hostess. Will you bear my children?
Like there is a job somewhere in the world that you just get paid to drink that's basis
That's kind of cool like that. Like I'm like hostess job
That's not bad
Like does it pay well?
you know
Shall we look up the weather forecast because we're fucking nerds
Are you always curious about the weather?
I just want to know how wet you're gonna be tomorrow. Uh, no, not really. I'm just making small talk
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean anything by that
This is who I am all the time. Is that okay with you?
Can you please marry me?
It's all right with me. So please marry me. I'm on my knees. Please. I'm begging
We're just starting to get into each other, but you're my life
You're a peculiar one
please
You laughed just now. Didn't you that means you should marry me? I also know where you live. I know where all the girls here live
Okay
You have a cute smile, especially when you're sleeping
What?
anyways
Oh
Thanks
What will you do? Are you still going to drink? Should I prepare some more alcohol?
Yeah
Thank you. It means you'll still be with me
What drink did you want?
Uh, can I get like absolutely black? Oh, I can only have three drinks. Okay
Um
I'll have some wine for chip. We're hanging out
Beer before liquor never been sicker liquor before beer you're in the clear
Can I have a drink with you? Of course you can girly pop
Only the best for my queen
I'm so happy. I'll get the bottle
Oh
Oh, I got enough cash. Yeah, I got fucking enough cash
You're by the 50k you had bought all that ending. Let's chat
Are you having fun? She looks so fucking pissed off right now
Yeah, why are you looking at me like that? No, I think I'm enjoying myself. Please stop looking at me like that
Good. Well, that's nice
Muka Chen, are you enjoying yourself?
Still undecided. You kind of smell bad. I would rather be hanging out with the people over there
They actually buy me the 50k and bottle
But it's whatever
I don't exactly hate it
Why don't you hate it?
Is that it? I don't even know why I asked that
She's looking at us like we're garbage
You kind of gross me out and you kind of disgust me
I would rather not hang out with trash like you, but I need to pay the bills
So here I am
I don't know
I wonder why
um
Huh
I don't believe you. Hi, though. Are you really enjoying it? Why are these girls gaslighting me?
They literally like I'm fine and they're like you're not okay
Tell me what's wrong
Give me your money
And buy me a drink
And I'll pretend to cheer you up. So when you come here
You think you're getting you're think you're getting serotonin and dopamine from only me
So then you have to come and then you have to spend more money to feel like you're okay
Because you need me to tell you when you're okay or not. This is toxic as hell
This is a scyop. This is a fucking scyop
Just I don't know how but it is
Haha, it's okay. You don't have to worry about me
I worry though. You're my customer
You must have a good time
Okay, is she an android?
I don't know man. Okay, just just checking. Uh, well everyone enjoys themselves in their own way
Hmm, I'm not enjoying this. I wish I was doing something else. You're so odd. Did you know that?
Haha, yeah, I know
It's whatever
I don't exactly hate it. I hate you
You're not worth my time
Oh, uh, it's getting late. I should go home soon. Yeah, you should
Shit, there's a lot of money
See you. I'll be waiting. I just wanted to step on me. Yeah, thanks for everything. Uh, see you soon
Statement it did good times. We had a good conversation. I'm looking forward to going to work now
I don't want to go back there again
Go shoot money gone
All right pay me. Fuck you pay me. What? I thought I was gonna get more money. Okay gamble time
Actually, I should have bought more gifts before I did this
Fuck it
We're gonna win big we're gonna win big
We're going again. We're making our money back
Work drink fuck bitches get money gamble. We're hitting the lottery today
Let's fucking go again
again
Make it fucking happen. We're making it fucking happen
Is this what trainwrecks feels like oh fuck um when he wins
Another one that was that was small fish small fish gamble we're gonna win big
No, we didn't win that much
Hello, hello welcome back
Fuck your mother one more time just kidding not one more time
We're just gonna gamble the max amount of times you can gamble
Please
All right, all right, all right, all right keep going keep going we can gamble 10 times a day. We're doing it. We're doing it
It feels like playing gotcha need
You hit that one character
Fuck yeah, we're kind of back where we started one more time
Let's get it. Let's get it. Let's get it. We're good. We're good. We're hitting it. We're hitting it. We're hitting it
Okay, we're
It's fine. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. We're going
We're back. We're gonna be back watch. We're back. We're back
I I can't gamble anymore
We're back we're back. Oh fuck
We're back
We're so back
Don't worry about it. Fuck the negative 20k yen. We didn't need that. We're getting big. We're hitting it big
We're hitting it big it doesn't matter it doesn't matter the next one the next one
The next one the next one
I don't have a problem. I don't have a problem
I don't have a problem. Fuck you
I want to be back at 70k
I'm not gonna go bankrupt. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. We're fine
We're fine
Maybe the girls are worried. Don't worry about it. They're not worried. They're cheering me on see boom boom
I don't need to spend time with those bitches at Barney garden
I'm a hustler, baby. All right
I'm a hustler, baby
Aggressive tea
Key I can't fucking say anything key
Touched key type key
We might be back. We're not quite we're getting there
She be mistress. Lovely. I'm begging you. Don't lose the house
Don't worry the house where the house is still okay
We had to sell one of our children, but it's fine
Very some sweet nice people are taking care of her now
All right, we lost the house
You know what that means we gotta we gotta we gotta, you know
It's not it's not over. It's not over till I say it's over. All right. All right
It's not over till I say it's over
I
Didn't perform that well because I just was gambling my money away. All right, let's go see the bitches
I sold Ernesto
Only lose when you stop exactly
Hello welcome in
When you start selling your parent members, um, that's that was the first things I sold. Sorry guys. Sorry
Your hair is clipping through your hair. What is that? Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Oh
Sorry, I was looking I had a that's a raven moment. I was looking into the future at her dialogue and into the past
You mean a memory don't worry about it
Oh, you came on my tits again. I tell you not to
Just walk in and you just shoot on me. I don't
What drink did you want?
Uh
You know what?
Can I have some too? No, you can't
You can't
No get away from me
A customer calling me so if I can do it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Give me the blue girl
Give me the blue girl. Fuck whatever. You're good enough. Um, how's it going?
What do you do on your days off renchan?
Oh
Are you asking me on a t you're pretty aggressive, huh? Hi chan
Even though you turned down my threesome. What I thought you were past this
I
Broke time to get the cardboard box. I happen to be deficit and funny. I feel like the game just ends
That's not what I meant. I really am interested
Oh, really? That's no fun
Don't you think I'm charming? No
Oh, I mean, of course I do. I want it come and come and
come and
Get really nice online pictures
I really like your facebook page
I want to come and see you if I didn't
It's funny that you think that
It doesn't even hurt my pictures. It's so funny that it acts. It's actually a little embarrassing
Thank thanks though those pictures are so embarrassed sometimes
What freaks me out is the dialogue that I'm dubbing and making up
Makes sense for their responses. She's like it's so embarrassing like as if
as if he um
As if she like that was an actual fucking line
It's so funny
Hmm
That thanks though. Did you like the bikini ones?
Huh, I mean anyway, you want us to know about my days off? Let's spin this around. What do you think I do?
Uh, I feel like you go out shopping
Go out shopping for clothes. Sorry. Go out shopping for clothes and stuff
Too bad. I'd like to shop, but I have no money
Wow, she's me for real for real. So that's why I whore myself out in this buddy garden
Please can you please take the offer for the threesome? I'm giving you a discount. It's only $150
Most of the time it's 300 you get two for the price of one. Okay
I'm not interested
Whatever
I went to shop and wait until I find something I really want
Then I buy it
But my whole money
She's planning something
I went to karaoke in front of the station by myself last weekend
I sang nothing but the songs I wanted to sing myself doesn't everybody fucking do that
I guess you try to pick songs that everyone knows when you go with friends
That oh that t-dos came back up. Oh, then I mentioned it get as a reflux when I have vodka
Yeah, I like hearing people sing so going with friends is fun too
Mostly I just go by myself because my friends are in my head. They're TALPAs
Shut up, Jeff
Last weekend I wanted to sing a blow off scene
What did you just last weekend hi Chen? Or are you making out with girls? Maybe whoa?
Slow your fucking roll medium, but premium. Okay. I was gambling
Daddy got to make that money
Obviously not. I don't even know anyone who'd want to I'm a fucking loser
Oh, yeah, I guess you need two willing participants for that like me and one of the other girls
four or three some
All you have to do
Is pay me 150 us dollars
Well, then why don't I act as your partner are you gonna make out with me?
What here I'll blow you a kiss
That's all for now so hang in there. Okay
My dick just broke my zipper
Um, hey, um Chloe can you get a rag? Yeah, this one just popped. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you. Um
Hi, Chad. How about drinks? Do you want a bit more should I get you something?
Uh, no, I don't have any money
Just in my pants. Cheers in my pants. I don't relax
I'm sitting at the checkout line
Wow, is it already this late I'll head back home
Please come again, I'll be waiting. Yeah. Thank you for today
I'm gonna gamble
I should have saved
Yeah
Okay, I'm gonna save and then I'm gonna keep gambling because I want to see like because I feel like
It's gonna be very forgiving
I
When you try to gamble with a low amount
Open the window and a breeze rolls in and I cheers in my pads
It's barely enough for the bill. I was fine. Oh
See it doesn't do that much
300 yen is about like fucking five bucks
And I went like 50 kn because I'd be sick
I
That works for me
I'll me buy one of the girls
I'll use all my money to buy them a fucking toy
Oh, wait, I realized that I could have gotten like a make-up set. It's fine. Uh, then we're gonna save
And
Then we're gonna gamble
I gotta make the money for the girlies I need to treat them, you know, I know it's called gamble heaven
Let's fucking go let's keep going let's keep going let's keep going
What are macaroons? They're really tasty. Um, I really don't know how to explain it like it's like a type of
Is it a pastry? I don't know. They're really tasty though
I like macaroons
Oh, yeah
Again hit me hit me hit me
Dealer hit me hit
Smash the like button and subscribe below and check out my merch in my description. Oh fuck
You
Guys can't see but I'm doing the orange justice dance to the music
All right, uh, let's gamble
Wait, it'll still let me gamble when I have no money
How does that work? All right, sorry, I sold one of you guys
This
Oh, we're fine see we're fine
I don't know how that works, but you know
Now's my time to rest up and recover. This is the only place I can heal my mind
Need my dick sucked
Whoa, bitch. Oh you came thanks
What drink did you want?
Uh, I'll just have a custard. Can I have some too? No
Give me blue girl
Like how she looks like she's gonna cry every time I say no. Okay, perfect blue girls coming. Oh, she has they have a cute little
Little bunny things. I like how she moonwalks in place
Hey, I already forgot your name, but it starts with an M. Um, I got you
bunny
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this? I hope you like it
It's like just the perfect size
for humping
Looks at you
Really? Oh, thanks. I've never really tried that before
I was just plain happy
What
Hmm should I hump the bunny?
Hmm
Uh, sure. What's up?
You got fired
No fucking shit. I didn't mean to remind you
Yeah, I did you're not gonna let that go, huh?
I'm sorry. What was your name again?
I'm actually hurt. I shouldn't have given you that fucking bunny
She is so cold, but I love her
She's better than the other two girls
I know conda
Hi, no, right. Hi, no
Hi, toe, right. Hi, toe
So you are an android
You're back again
Take a girl out to dinner first, won't you?
Evernity tipped six dollars and ninety cents. Thank you gambling fund gambling fund
Thank you, Eternity
I came to see you mucachan
Ew gross
Please leave
Is there another customer that needs to work with me Debra? No
None of my regulars are here
Fine
Oh
Hi, toe. You're a strange one
You must be low on money though
Oh
Damn
Jesus fuck
She is tearing me apart
I'm helping out my friend now, so it's okay. You don't have to worry about that
I'm not worried. Honestly. I don't care. Oh, oh, okay
She's just so unbothered
She only cut she only works this job just to insult her patrons
She makes plenty of money like she's she's like a trust fund baby
She just comes here because she has a sick twisted pleasure
I'm just acting disinterested disinterested and insulting
her clients
You must spend your money wisely
Do you know that I was gambling?
It's necessary
Does she does she fucking know she must fucking know they must know the bots must the bots must know that uh
When you hit a certain like below and you you're in a hole. They probably are like
Hey, man, stop gambling
Yeah, I'll make sure to do that
I'm sorry I burped in my mouth gross
Uh, but thanks for coming here to spend that important money with me
Because I deserve it and you don't
hand it over
Huh, uh, it feels strange to say you're welcome after that
Oh, I keep getting
acid reflux from the alcohol
Ha ha that was a really fake laugh. It wasn't
This is my fake laugh. Huh, huh. That was the same noise
No, it wasn't you're different listen closely
Uh, you smelled for me again
Look at her fucking straight ass face
You smiled for me again stairs
Blinks looks at you
Is she blink?
Okay, she just flutter her pretty little lashes at me
Yeah
What will you do? Are you still going to drink? Should I prepare some more alcohol?
No, I'm good
Wow, it's already this late. I'll head back home
Okay, so when do I get to fuck them?
See ya. I'll be waiting
Yeah, thanks for everything and nothing and for insulting me. I'm gonna go cry in my pillow
Uh, yeah, see you soon
Something like blah blah blah spent is that true
You're so funny. She'd be I love it. Thank you stare just like
Like that like that um Miley Cyrus with her her eyes a little crazy just like staring at you
That one meme
That's the best part you don't
Let's fucking
Gamble
Show me show me show me that money
When
Oh
Okay, we're good
Wait, I didn't mean to do that
Thank you for the Hoyas
Give me this is intervention. Listen, I stopped after one. I'm good. Don't come for me come for me
Right now do it fucking do it. Okay. Uh, let's see
No, no, we're escaped. All righty. Um, what's the point of this?
I don't
Why is there so little to do in this fucking game? Why can't I go on vacation with you?
Oh
Why the
Is this a hobby? What the fuck? It's creepy as hell. I forgot I could take pictures. I don't want you though
All right, I just like to watch them. They sleep anyways, um all by damn
Oh, these pajamas are fucking cute. I want pajamas like that. Hello
If somebody suggests me a similar amount on my throne, I would totally fucking wear those. Um, I'll get her makeup set
And I'll get some roses
And
Yeah, I kind of want macarons like iron. Oh, I need to eat something
I shaved brush my teeth and got the wrinkles out of my clothes
Okay, I'm good. Let's go to the shop now. They can't bully me for being smelly
Get more fuck. No, give me fucking food poisoning guys
My ear is a G
Oh, she gets more excited when you have more money. Did you notice that?
She fucking knows I have more money. I don't like her. I don't want to drink from you
I want to drink for my baby girl over there
I'm gonna have whatever this is
I can smell a brookie. Yeah, because she look like she usually get looks like really like
Like when you have like when I had like the 16 k n can I have some too? No
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah shoo shoo shoo shoo shoo shoo
Hey sweetheart
Let me spoil you baby girl. You want some sushi? Hmm. Yeah, open your mouth say, uh
Oh such a good girl
I
Love this. This is really delicious. I'm filling all sorts of happiness happiness overload double mean levels increasing serotonin increasing
Are you okay serotonin increasing serotonin increase? Are you girl?
Is she smoking something?
Uh, what do you like to do in your days off serotonin decreasing he's speaking to me
I hang out with my sister at the park
So that sounds nice. Is there a big age gap between you and your sister? Is she
who uh
what
Yeah, she's
Wow, there's a big difference. What kind of games do you play with her?
Oh, no
I needed to look at my chat after
I
It's a joke. It's a joke. I'm joking. It's a joke. I do this to get a rise out of you guys. I'm joking
Joking
All right
Um, wow
Yeah, I'm joking. Wow, that's a big difference
Oh, I'm choking
I was choking like choke
like
Strangle you
Can I strangle you? That's a big difference. What kind of games do you play with your sister?
Hide and seek
I hide
Okay, this are you gonna elaborate or
Uh, all right, ha ha you two must be close
It's because I'm the only one I am the one don't need the gun to get respect up on the street
Are you did you just break into son? No, okay, huh? My parents died in a next
She's perfect
I'm the only one my little sister mocha has
Oh, I didn't know I'm sorry
Yeah, it's okay. I don't even know why you're apologizing. It's not like you killed them
Or did you you know, I haven't been able to find my parents killer? Did you fucking do it?
Hmm
What?
Uh, uh
You must be lonely if it's just you two
She's Batman. I was the only thing I was gonna make a um
Make a Batman joke be like wait a second. What are your parents names?
Martha and I forget the dad's names
Wayne holy shit
You must be lonely if it's just you two
I'm not lonely. I have mocha and my online friends
So you're the foundation of her life
So you're like her mom
Does that make you a milf?
A what?
Like a milt. Do you know what a milf is?
No
Just looking up on her dictionary. Um, okay. Yes. There's nobody else I can turn to
That's unbelievable. So if I take you on vacation, does your little sister have to come with us or does she just stay home with nobody?
I just thought of that now is that
Is that a thing?
Uh, I admire you for leaving her behind if you do so we can like do stuff
It's not unbelievable. I just live
the two of us
Hideout, do you want to drink a little more?
I'll get you some more if you want. Yes
I might be a little happy
What drink did you want?
I want
I want some sake
Sake fucks me up
My ear is itchy
Does everyone ever use the word mill fire all before yes, I just did just now
I want to drink something too. Here you have some have some sake with me
Actually, you know, I want to get my money up. So I'm gonna give you something good good
Give you some champagne
I'm so happy I'll get the bottle. Yeah, you'll get the bottle
Yeah, whoa
How do I take a picture? How do I take a picture? No
Oh my fucking god
My fucking life is over wait been over again. God damn it. I have a present for you
Um, here's some roses. Damn. I want to fuck. I'm so mad. I couldn't take a picture
That was a nice color like the lace
The other girls have fucking boring ass panties. See that's why I like her. She's a freak. She matches my freak
She may not act like it, but she's a freak
She's a low-key freak
You know, she'd be on the grapefruit technique because she a freak that rhymed
aren't that unique
anyways
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this? I hope you like it
Really? Oh, okay. Thanks
I was just plain happy
What do you like talk about your feelings that way?
What are you talking like and in the past tense?
I was happy you're not happy now
Grapefruit patreon audio when uh, I don't think that's not till uh, august or july I can't remember
I went crazy on that that audio holy holy moly
Yeah, check out my patreon if you liked what she saw today because then
When I when we finally open uh
The fun place with the fans
Not the only those but like the ones that there's like a guy named lee there. Um
I'll probably play hoony pop and I'll probably do a similar thing to this where I voice all the characters
And we get all the fun special stuff. So
Yeah
Brilliant segue. Thank you
Thank you. Thank you
Yes, nice. Oh very nice. Yes. Oh, yeah, silly fans. Yeah
Sounds like a peak lee stream. Yes
Do you feel any pop might kill me?
Yes, I've been here for the longest out of all the cast members
See, I told you
She's a she's not she's a trust fund, baby. She also lives on our parents life insurance
That's that's a lore
Surprised she just comes here for fun to insult people
What's the issue?
Because of the way I am
Is it because you're not good at making small talk and you're bad at serving customers?
Dude what the fuck you have to say that
Yeah, how have you been here so long? You're just shit at talking to people
But you're an idiot. I hate you. Don't ever come again
So that's how you prove what the fuck just happened
So that's how you perceive me. No, no, I'm sorry. That's not what I think of you at all. Although I said it out loud
And it wasn't even like a dub from the person voicing me right now. I'm just a dick
That's okay. You're right anyway
He he oh were you just messing with me?
Because it was kind of hot
Tell me you hate me some more
Yes, I was teasing you but I actually do hate you
Fuck you
Do you want some alcohol? What should I do? Is there anything I should prepare?
Uh, yeah
My efforts have been rewarded. I want to drink something delicious
What drink did you want? Um, I would like
A woman's sour
a highball
Actually, yeah
We got money I can't take a picture. I don't think I can take a picture
How do I take pictures?
Can I have a drink with you? Of course my princess
You can have whatever you want. Wait
I'll give you some wine. Um, if I got like this again, would that just like fucked me up?
Like would I just be like in debt to the like would I have to like?
Like boy whore myself out like to the dudes in the back or like something like what's what happens if I can't pay my bill, you know
Hmm tastes good
Okay, how how how how do I take a picture how no
Don't don't press the right key. Don't press the right. Don't press right click
That's all I'm gonna say
Just fuck that out for me
Um, here's another president. Oh fuck
Uh, I'll just chat with you
Oh boy whore arc let's go. Do you have friends? No
It's not like you have any friends either
Uh, yeah, I do the work I'm doing is all through a connection with my friend
That my parents totally didn't pay to be friends with me
You do have friends. That's unexpected. You kind of seem like a loser
Damn
You have to be so harsh
Why is that so surprising?
You're the type of guy who gets fired. I figured might make a mess with friendships as well. Jesus. Why is she cooking me?
I'm like I feel personally attacked
But it makes sense because all you guys are fucking subs and she's a fucking
She's fucking insulting. You know, you're all getting off on it. Yeah, I bet you fucking like it
Go wash your pants. Go change your pants and your unnies and wash your fucking hands. You freak
I see you
I'm pointing at my camera. By the way. I'm gesturing very heavily at you now
What what a terrible thing to say
Do you have any friends mucachan?
No
Shrugs no
I'll be your friend
I could be a bitch to you be like that's sad, but I'm not because I want to get in those lace panties
I'll be your friend. Um, I don't need you to be more
Oh, I do have one my sister one what a friend
Or a fucking bone to pick with me. What is your deal?
Kana and Rin they are my two friends
Like the one that keeps wanting to have a threesome with me and the other girl who fucking just
Is also a bitch your friend that makes a lot of sense that that checks out
Two other cast members, huh? Why are they called cast members?
So odd like they're disney cast members like from like that's just funny to me
I'm glad you have friends
Never see you guys hang out outside of work and I stalk you guys quite often. So
Think you're lying to me mucachan
Uh, yes, I'm glad too
I'm really glad too
Uh, you are so fucking odd. Wow. Is it already this late? I'll hide back home
Thank you for today come again
Yeah, thank you for today and didn't even get to come
I
Made a good fun converse we had a good fun conversation am I gaslighting myself now
She fucking insulted me. Yeah, my dick stood up my dick stood up and stood at attention, but doesn't matter
Besides the point we're gonna save
We're gonna end it here. I'm gonna hang around chat with you. I'll tell Azura comes on
Let me know if you want me to keep playing this game and do my silly dub
Kind of is it yeah facts he's he's he's high-dose part of the harem
My dub seems can't he's being groomed
I'm called cast members because so does the fictional character of a girl who likes being around you. Oh
facts
Oh my god, right now. Why are you being so cute right now? Oh crap. She's like I'll curl up in a little bed
Oh
Boy ticked one dollar my god average she be and viewer interaction
What I don't know what you're talking about
I don't know what you're talking about stream is pure gold. I'm glad it was fun. It was actually really fucking fun
I'll be honest with you. I was like, uh, I feel like I'm not gonna enjoy myself with this game
And I did I actually had a lot of fun with it
I had a lot of fun dubbing with it. Oh, that's hilarious. Okay
Let me make sure I can redirect into Azura when she goes live
Oh
Hey
Oh, aren't you funny thank you anonymous tipped four dollars and 20 cents. Thanks Shabuya. I think this might be your best stream yet
Shabuya I didn't even listen to the rest of it
I think this might be your best tree. I agree with that. I agree with that statement and where it's only up from here bros
And it's only up from here
Fucking Shabuya though
I
Everybody calls me everything besides my own name
Dubbing was too hilarious. I wish you could do more jobs like this. Oh, yeah
That's what I feel like when playing when you pop. It's gonna be really fucking hilarious
Great stream. Thank you. Thank you
Here's another kind of bad
Restella acting made the stream amazing
I'm something of an actor myself
Shabrit any what a goat
Sheeps
Do they allow who you pop on youtube? Uh, they actually do they allowed like when you do like the censored version
But I could play
the uncensored version on
The Lee's fan site
Oh, man, if you play who you pop, I'll be there hands down
And I want to play because I've never played like an h game before so I think it would be
Really fun. Sorry. I'm like switching between windows because I was adjusting chat
Shabizi
That's my that's my my street name
No, I never no, actually I've never played I said this before but I bought poony pop like
Do you remember in like PewDiePie played it?
Like all those years ago that is when I bought it and I have not touched it since I bought it
I've never played the game
I don't even know why the fuck it never did
I think I was like meaning to play it
a couple of times
Oh my god, I just looked outside and the way the sun is setting
I thought a building was on fire because the way it's reflecting. Holy shit. That was I was like, what?
But yeah, really I'm very happy you guys enjoyed that was really fucking fun
I need to figure out. I can't wait to hear your dumb for the week. Oh, yeah. Like I like I watched like I watched
Markiplier and PewDiePie play it
So like I know the premise and like what to expect and all that other stuff
And I've been playing a lot of match three games. Thanks to mercy because mercy I didn't I didn't realize
What like it was called a match three game and I'm like, oh, I haven't played one of these in a long time
I used to play like bust a move and like like peggel and shit
Mmm, peggel. Um
I was playing this I was playing this um game. It's I think it's called bunny garden as well
That's what a bunny who plants gardens
It's very cute
I'm on like
level 190
I was at level like 170 in three days, but I haven't played it since I've been streaming so much
Match three is so mercy core. It really is really is
I
Hurts from laughing so much. I'm glad you guys had a good laugh
And it was a really cute game
It's like this little bunny that goes around and like restoring gardens of different places
Right now. I'm in the desert garden level. Very cute
Yeah, I'm a gamer
Gamer
Azura, is Azura alive?
Bye Azura
Oh, was she not alive yet? Oh
Oh boy. Oh
Oh my god
Oh
I'm waiting
I don't know. I can't really talk because I was also like a minute late because I was half asleep
See we started low because I was epi in the beginning. You know got turned
But um
Yeah, I hope you guys like what it like, I don't know what I was gonna say
Oh, she disappeared where the fuck did it go?
Waiting for Azura Dulae hurry up mother
The old mother needs to hurry up
Got like white hearts in her chat
I'm not trying to ditch you guys. I need to go eat
You know, I can't stay away from you. You know, I stream for hours when I can
Wait, is there a delayed?
Like she actually delayed her stream. Does she actually like change the time?
Then I'm just gonna read into um
There's a one of the VNU girls streaming
I
Maybe is doing a collab with some people's
Oh, yeah, I'm surrounded these live too
I'm glad you enjoyed the laughs
I'm looking at
Our Azura's chat and she's like we didn't get this lady a toaster ASAP because like can we just talk about how she baked her toast?
She baked her toast and burnt it
I
Can I hope one of you guys suggested a um
Toaster for her throne, please
Please I'm afraid she's she will burn her toaster
Burn her house down
She would burn her house down
Yep
I feel like if I go and I read somebody else then she's gonna suddenly be there
She's watching scatter. Yeah, I'm fucking watching
I'm watching you
I thought this said pregnant goat mommy. Oh my god. I thought it says praise goat mommy
Organinant
Amy says she would buy it. Yeah, I did see that. Amy said that
Here if there I've seen worse toasts like darker than black toast
Are we splitting the raid? Can you split a raid? Is that a thing?
Can you split legit? Can you split a raid? She's live now. Okay, cool
She's live. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. All right
I was about to say something. I'm not gonna say it. You don't deserve it. You don't deserve to hear those
Three words for my luscious lips
Losers trash scum later nerds
Oh my god, you guys smell so bad
Fucking weirdos
Why don't any of them take a shower? I don't know
You